good morning everyone
bill wallace meeting of the house
judiciary committee to order
and we'll begin by
pledging our allegiance to the flag and
representative horrigan would you lead
us today
to the republic for which it stands
under god individual liberty and justice
thank you
mr clerk would you mind calling the role
representative gordon here
representative mclean here
representative sylvia
representative welper is here
representative alexander is not
representative green is not
representative nodder
representative merner is not
representative kelly is not
representative trottier is not
representative smith
oh i'm sorry representative andrus
uh representative smith is here
representative burch is not
representative oregon
representative lorenzo
representative chase is not
representative kenny is not
representative langley is not
representative macbeth is not
oh representative langley is
representative
simpson that morning representative
simpson
good morning
he is
don't sing langley yes
take out the no
representative chase just walked in the
door okay
uh representative page i never called
his name but he's not here
now i have
good morning everyone we're our first
item in business this morning is a
hearing it's a hearing on senate bill
375 relative to requirements for
charitable organizations
the prime sponsor that bill being
senator gannon and senator gannon
good morning would you like to introduce
your bill i would thank you
representative gordon thanks for having
me
um i always love being over on this side
of the wall because i learned there's 20
of you usually in most committees and
there's only five of us so you get a
much broader view of everything and it's
a good thing
um i am senator william gannon i
represent district 23
and we call it the wine country now of
so if we are traveling of new hampshire
we are surrounded by lebels uh zorvino's
flag hill winery so if you ever have a
free weekend you could do a nice wine
tour and um and that doesn't mean you
have to leave out our lovely published
establishments either so come see my
beautiful lake district of new hampshire
and be glad to see you especially if i
get a cheaper gas tax representative
smith
um anyways but i'm here today to
introduce the charity protection act
so what the idea is you asked me
representative smith so i'll start with
your question and see if i can help you
representatives of the charitable
foundations came to me and said
all across the country were getting over
regulated
we have no problems especially with
the secretary of state or the charitable
trust division
we're fine with the regulations they
have
but around the country we're getting
onerously burdened by too much paperwork
and it's requiring more staff to very
more attention
and it's not a problem with what they
have on file it's just because certain
states especially all around the country
are now saying
we want more we want more and so it's a
never-ending battle especially for
summer with certain charities there
seems to be certain charities that
certain states are going against and so
we don't want that to happen in new
hampshire and again in new hampshire
everything's running fine they want to
be regulated by
the charitable trust division they don't
mind the paperwork
and again however all around the country
their vet which are becoming burdensome
on these charities and their primary
task is helping us
with the people most in need we want as
much of their resource sources going to
the people of new hampshire and helping
the people who need our aid and not
going to unduly burdensome
tasks of paperwork and that's why i
passed when it was presented to me that
way it seemed like a relatively
straightforward bill
and i welcome any questions there are
experts who are going to testify who i'm
more of a jack of all trades who knows a
little bit about of a lot of bills in
the senate um but i will try to ask
answer any questions especially yours
representative smith
other questions for the senator
represent representative smith
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question i've listened
carefully to what you said and you
talked about all kinds of agencies in
other states
doing draconian things to
charitable agencies
but this bill prohibits new hampshire
state agencies and officials from
imposing filing or reporting
requirements it says nothing about what
other states are doing can you clarify
that
to me i think i can um so the problem is
in new hampshire where things are
relatively fine now we do not other
states have been overly burdensome on
many charities throughout the country we
don't want it's we're gonna head that
off here we're happy with the
requirements they're asking for now
under under a different administration
we just wanted it to be at a level
playing field that they're not going to
all of a sudden say
more more more so they have to hire
staff to do that it's just a
preventative measure
representative mclean
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um
these other states that are
throwing on all these additional
regulations
what's what's the driver behind that in
those other states um what concerns
are kind of pushing that and are we not
seeing those concerns in new hampshire
um so just trying to understand we
haven't as of yet
it's political concerns towards certain
groups certain charities that are maybe
not politically in favor be it um
you could either side of like a life
issue they may be pro-life they may be
anti and they'd be maybe tougher on one
group than another group and
it's just uh that's just one could be
one area
and
we want everyone on a level playing
field in new hampshire which we feel
they are and we think this is just going
to set parameters and keep it the way it
is
other questions
representative horgan did you have a
question
yes there was um
and of course we've had a one of the
one of the groups that uh sent us an
email opposing this was a group that
sends us emails on many other uh
political issues and um
which is in fact uh state director is
the former chief of staff for a former
republican speaker of the house so we
all know who it is and i don't want to
attack him he's within his rights doing
what he's doing but
um
do we
are you trying to prevent us from doing
anything about and they're they're both
on the left and the right and everywhere
in between these groups that are in fact
political advocacy groups but for
um
various reasons mostly taxes and privacy
choose to structure themselves as 501 c
3s even though they're not
even though they're
in many cases quite political so
i don't know if if the question was are
we protecting or the left to the right
no we want them all treated the same
i'm sorry i misunderstood your question
that yeah but
do we
want to follow up is there some extent
do we want regardless of what side their
advocacy is on do is
do we have the state of any interest in
perhaps
encouraging groups like that to be
political epic to be something other
claim to be something other than a
non-political you know tax-free charity
i i think
you're getting into the area of politics
and i i'm not gonna
okay are there other questions
seeing none thank you very much have a
great day you too
senator khan
actually this is rare we have two
senators today this is
i guarantee there are three over there
right now
and
senator again and i will join them very
shortly because we've got a lot of bills
that came over recently
so mr chairman i'm jay kahn uh
state senator from keene representing 15
of 23 towns in cheshire county
so i am here in support of senate bill
395 375 excuse me um
the
uh
i'll just convey as a short story and uh
attorney donovan will uh correct it once
i'm done
but
i don't think a year ago you saw a bill
that i'd introduced
regarding the
the floor at which a
financial audit would be required of
charitable organizations
at the time i was working with
the
uh
not-for-profits organizations within the
state
to try to see
if a million-dollar level
and this is what's uh in
the end of the bill in section three
um
if a million dollar level is the right
level still
after
the last time that this was uh
updated which i think was in 2004 but
attorney donovan
has the the right figures
on that 2004.
anyway
we we uh
the organ the
conversation with the organizations
was
uh
do we lift the level from 1 million
to
anywhere up to 5 million dollars
there are about
700 organizations that
i actually know it's around 450
organizations
that uh
have annual revenues and expenses uh at
a million dollars
and there are about 120
of those that
have revenues between 1 million and 2
million dollars
so the proposal here
to raise it to 2 million would be the
first raising of that level since 2004.
it covers
about 150
not for profits
that then would not be doing uh
financial st audits
they would still be submitting their 990
forms
like all not-for-profits do to
the division of charitable trusts
and
the
ability to continue to do audits
is would rest with the organization
at that two million dollar level it
becomes required on an annual basis
so here's the difference that this makes
as has been explained to me by the 1
million organizations
and
it's that
they're spending about 15 000
a year on
uh the preparation of the
uh
comprehensive audit
um
and
uh that's a significant amount of the
opportunity money that they have
for annual awards for purpose
of the organization
the higher you go in annual revenues the
smaller fifteen thousand dollars becomes
but it's a flat amount
uh so this uh effort
to to raise this is something that both
the financial auditing
folks
uh which is the accounting organization
in the state
and the not-for-profit organization in
the state
both were in favor of lifting this
last year we've proposed three million
dollars in further conversation with
attorney donovan uh
some level it should it it could be
raised and still be competitive with the
other 50 states uh in in their policies
um he just felt that if we tried to
raise it to three million dollars it was
beyond where we should be lifting it
so
uh hopefully this amendment this year is
uh uh amenable to the legislature and uh
we can proceed to relieve that financial
burden
uh from
uh the required filings by
not-for-profit organizations at a
million to two million dollars
representative wolper do you have a
question
i do mr chairman thank you and thank you
for taking my question uh you spoke
about uh the
120 i believe it was you said
uh organizations that were between one
and two million that would be exempted
from auditing by this bill
and
i thought you said it cost them about 15
million dollars a year
are you talking about 15 000 each or 15
million dollars altogether no it's 15
000 if i've said that incorrectly i'm
apologize 15 thousand dollars is
that's each
there ought to be per per
organization thank you
representative smith
thank you mr chair um
senator khan you addressed um
section 3
of
this bill um
changing from 1 million to 2 million but
you said nothing about the
the other parts of the bill
do you have um anything to share with us
about the other parts of the bill
i don't
i
obviously i voted in favor of the bill
thank you
other questions
representative sylvia
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
for the
organizations that are below
whatever minimum is
what what is the standard practice for
their um finances and without an audit
or are they doing a more simple audit um
do you know what the general practice is
i think it varies because we're talking
about the you know such a broad range of
organizations fifty thousand dollars up
to
uh a million
um
they all
comply with the 990 forms
so
if you're familiar with those
it's a statement of financial position
with
revenues and expenses
cash
and and uh the primary expenses of the
organization
uh
including personnel
so uh
yeah i i
mean that's
and so what the the auditors just don't
feel like they are adding that much
value
uh
i'll leave that actually to mr donovan
to to explain but uh
they thought
that this is a requirement that could be
relaxed by to to organizations in this
1 million to 2 million
sorry thank you
other questions
yes representative langley
thank you mr chair um good morning
senator can you help me understand
how this legislation will impact upon
the requirements of becoming a 501c3
or if it has any impact on that
on the application process no i don't
believe so
but but the requirements once you've
been 501 speed 3.
well yes it
um the
the uh
as i understand you you're one will this
affect
501 c 3 not for profits correct yes
in terms of auditing
they would they'll
again i
they're required to complete a financial
position statements of financial
position in the 990 forms
federal 990s
those will not be audited
for that small group that
sits between a million and two million
dollars of revenue a year
thank you representative lorenzo
thank you mr sharon thank you for taking
my question center um you mentioned the
word audit and um could you explain who
would be the auditing the entity that
would be doing the auditing thank you
um
well they did um
boy
trying to remember the three that are
the primary ones
but baker newman noise is one
just for an instance
they uh
they're they're all aicpa
uh recognized
organizations
follow up so it would be the um
an outside auditing firm correct yes
okay probably from within the state all
right thank you yes
representative chase thank you mr chair
and thank you for taking my question i
um would like you to repeat to me if you
would the organizations you were saying
that the non-profits between a certain
amount of money will not be audited
what was that what was that um amount
this is raising that auditing cap
or the floor
actually right uh
from one million to two million dollars
correct but you had just before senator
um deloranzo asked you said something
about this would not will affect the
501cs the 990s still have to be filled
out but will not be audited and you said
organizations between and you gave a
certain amount of money it was way under
the million
so the little guys
you said 50 million anything that's
below the floor now okay
uh
isn't
oh you don't they do the form 990s on an
annual basis
thank you yes and mr donovan
maintains those i've been on some
not-for-profit boards i know
the filing date and how they follow up
with the organizations if you fail to
file
and
it's
he does a good job
other questions
yes representative andrus
thank you mr chair and thank you senator
to taking my question
my question is if this was changed to
two million dollars and there wouldn't
be an audit anything under it would it
be possible to make a change and do
random audits every year a small amount
and that just keeps everybody's on their
toes thank you
you know
i asked that question of the auditors
and they said
that really wouldn't be of much value
they come in and do that
on an organization's request
but
it's more um
it's a lot of work
for them to not have had
the uh
the annual
relationship with the company
or with with the not-for-profit
and that's that's the way they reported
it they said
yeah it seemed logical to me as well
uh
but
they said that
did the amount of startup uh to do that
there there'd be overcharging
for that initial
uh
every three five year kind of thing
do you know of any charitable
organizations that have asked for the
change yes
they have approached me and and once
into it
we
it became clear and uh
we've had the benefit in testimony a
year ago uh
from people to that uh
it's just it's time it's it's time to
come back and take a look at what we did
in establishing the level
and considering
what an appropriate level today would be
and
i i yield to
attorney donovan he uh
he's a good judge of what he does and if
he's
amenable to a two million dollar cap
that it will help a number of
organizations that i'm familiar with
thank you
representative smith
thank you mr chair um senator i don't
know if it's you or mr donovan who would
be best to answer
um i
wonder if there's a need to clarify
when we use the word audit i think we're
talking about two different things
on the one hand we're talking about a
large
agency not-for-profit agency charitable
agency
being required as part of its own due
diligence to hire an outside auditor to
come in
and verify the accuracy of their books
that's entirely separate from the work
that charitable trusts would do
in
making sure
representing the interests of the state
not the the agency
repre making sure that all
um
all
charitable operations in the state
are reviewed for example i'm the
treasurer of the durham historic
association and at forty four thousand
dollars a year
i have to fill out a form
and file it and in due course
charitable trust make sure that we're
doing what we should do that's entirely
separate
from what we're talking about here so
that it's not
that
those organizations up to 1 million or 2
million or whatever would not be
within the responsibility
of charitable trust it's just that
they're not going to have to hire
an expensive accounting firm
to do an external audit
am i correct in that
i wish i would have added that to my
testimony if i fail so
it's an excellent explanation thank you
very much
are there any other
questions or explanations
okay thank you very much for your
testimony thank you chairman gordon
and
attorney donovan
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee my name is tom donovan i'm the
director of charitable trust at the
attorney general's office we have
responsibility for oversight of the 11
charitable organizations that do
important work every day in our state
everything from our large hospitals and
private colleges down to local little
leagues and historical societies and
everything in between
as is common we do not take a position
on sb 375
i can report that there were
we had some concerns about the language
as introduced in the senate and there
were
uh changes made and uh we feel
comfortable with the amendments that
were made and then um
senator khan's amendment added section 3
about
changing the floor for audits so i'd be
happy to answer any questions that
members may have about this
we're going to be back this afternoon on
another bill sb 302
um
which also relates to charities and we
are opposing that bill i can't be there
my assistant director diane quinlan will
be there for that but that's a different
bill
questions for attorney donovan
i guess uh the question just with regard
to the increase from a million dollars
to two million dollars is is that
something that is appropriate in
appropriate change in this day and age
is it it reflects uh inflation to uh
sure and we look at what other states do
and it's it's sort of on the high side
for a floor but we feel comfortable
with it we're sensitive to the fact that
it's an expense
because
the organizations do have to hire an
outside cpa firm and that does cost
money
senator khan mentioned 15 000 a year
some firms would charge that that's on i
think on the high side some would charge
less it's just like lawyers or other
providers they have different some are
more expensive than others but
it certainly is an expense
and we're sensitive to that
if i could just follow up on that
it seem it seems that it would be
typical for organizations to be audited
in some
way
is this
is it
do you believe as a result of making
this change
that there are
organizations that will decide to no
longer be audited or would they
typically be audited that's a good
question
some organizations have
other requirements to be audited
independent of ours for instance i
believe some organizations that may have
a contract with dhhs
or a federal agency they may have a
requirement as a term of that grant or
contract to have an audit
uh so that that would not be affected by
this
but i do believe there will be some
organizations um
senator khan mentioned the constituent
of his who
has revenue between a million and two
million
and
likely we'll cease having an audit
other questions
i guess i i do have another question if
i could and that's with regard to the
first part of the bill and basically the
testimony that i've heard with regard to
that is
there's no really no problem in new
hampshire as of right now
but this is sort of anticipated
anticipatory
and that we don't want any type of
problem i get i guess the question is
and
so the question that i have is is it
necessary to pass legislation if
there's no immediate purpose for it
so that's a judgment call i can't
can't comment on that
thank you
representative smith
chair um
mr donovan let me
um
follow up on the chairs question in a
slightly different way
um
have you in your professional
uh
area of authority
recognized
any
problem
that exists in the state of new
hampshire and how
we
manage
filing and reporting requirements
so
i
um
i think that our old forms needed work
and we have changed them
um particularly for smaller
organizations
um
i
one of the charges that was placed on me
when i got hired seven years ago was to
have allow online filing to make it
easier and we've now implemented that
and i think that that helps i think it's
not so much what is being requested
but um
how
um
inconvenient it is to get people to to
do that and so we've been looking at
ways to streamline it
so we get the information we need to do
our job but to do it in a way that's not
unduly burdensome for the charities
thank you may i follow up
um so um
are you saying that under
current law
you have
the authority to make sure
that you can do
the
the most appropriate job possible to
monitor charitable trusts including
making changes in practices
to conform with the changing world
um
yes but
the world of fundraising has changed um
in recent years um
because of online giving which is a good
thing
there's good gofundme and all sorts of
other opportunities
and
are some of our statutes about
fundraising were written before there
was an internet
and so the laws we currently have were
designed for a pre-internet era so i
think
um
on my to-do list in the to-do list of
people in my position around the country
is to
think about ways to uh
address that and that likely would have
to happen by regulation and the big
thing would be
disclosures to the public
sometimes when people are giving through
these platforms they don't realize that
maybe the money could be redirected to
another organization or it might take a
month or two months for the for the
charity to get the money
um we were recently
um
um had looked into facebook because
there was a charity that took
didn't get their money for a year well
it turns out there had been an issue
with respect to bank account numbers and
things like that but
um we were concerned about that we think
legislation
could help with that could i follow up
just once more
you may thank you very much so um do you
anticipate then
that
um the first uh part of this bill which
seems if i'm reading it correctly say
we can't whatever we're doing now is
okay but we can't make other changes
do you see that as conceivably
interfering with your ability
to carry out all the work that you
in the
incredibly
fine tradition of charitable trusts
would want to do
let me answer it this way uh
representative if we were going to make
a change on the try it propose to make a
change with respect to online giving
we'd come to you and and propose a bill
thank you
and i guess i did if i could just that
because you you mentioned well there are
some things that we might need to do
you referred to gofundme
and the way monies are being used
particularly with regard online and you
mentioned regulation but
if i read this correctly
regular you would not be able to do
regulation
in terms of administrative rules you
would actually have to come to the
legislature and make statutory changes
i think that's right
representative lorenzo
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question mr donovan um
you know as we were speaking about
charities i
thought about charitable gaming
and wondering about you know
regulating and auditing charitable gang
gaming
yeah so um
luckily uh lottery takes care of the
oversight of charitable gaming not us
and they do have
um good oversight uh and i know there
have been
situations where there's been abuse with
charitable gaming
and we hear and we'll hear it we'll be
informed about that but they do
a form of audit with respect to that
portion of the money
so that's certainly an area of concern
but lottery's got a lot of eyes looking
at that
representative chase thank you very much
and thank you for taking my question uh
mr donovan so just because i don't
understand all of this and i want to are
you saying that all the online gofundmes
and these other fundraisers do you
actually have
you have to look at these and make sure
that they're legitimate or how is this
affecting the charitable trust
okay so there are and i'll try not to
take too much time um
there's big c capital c charity and
small seek charity
um the bulk of giving on gofundme for
instance
is um
my name is john smith and my wife needs
help paying medical bills
that is small c charity
uh
uh it's one person asking for help for
an individual that is not regulated by
our office at all
big c charity also happens on gofundme
to a lesser extent and that is where
um
let's say the red cross um is
uh raising money
and want and is using gofundme as
as one means to do so
that would be regulated by us and a
number of small red cross isn't a good
example
maybe the
historical society would be more likely
to you to do a gofundme campaign
and
we would have some concern to protect
the charity and also the donor
that that um things are going correctly
and it's not just gofundme it's also
facebook um
amazon um
smile
um go uh paypal
there are a lot of these online
platforms and we just have concerns that
that we don't want to discourage it
because it's a it's a way for people to
give money quickly simply and it's a way
for charities to raise money
and we sure would prefer that
uh
um in comparison with those annoying
phone calls you get at home
and we're actually seeing there's less
of that happening because so much of
giving is moved online
just one follow-up representative chase
sorry thank you
that just
that was very clear thank you i
understand now one other thing though is
what about like the giving tuesday and
these other kickoffs the 603s that we
get now is this where did those fall so
those um
uh those are great opportunities and but
those charities
should all be registered with us
and what we find the new hampshire
center for nonprofits does
give new hampshire
events every so often and they have
requirements
including that they be in good standing
with our office
and so you'd be amazed how many
charities that are not in good standing
with us clean get their
delayed reports in to us so they can be
in good standing so they can participate
so those sorts of things we really
encourage
any other questions yes representative
simpson
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question i am wondering back to the
um
changing the cap from or the exemption
from a million dollars to two million
dollars uh i was wondering right now how
many
questions inquiries investigations do
you have say from donors asking about
financial information about
charities or organizations that are
below the 1 million right now per year
yeah
um
we
we get a couple of calls a week
from people asking
about
charities and you know are they legit
etc
then there are
we post all of the charities on our
website and we either indicate whether
they're in good standing or not in good
standing so we
um
i don't have
we can track that uh but i don't have
any information about that but yeah
people do
ask that and um it's publicly available
information so they can get the form 990
if they ask for it so we can give that
to them
other questions
see thanks for your testimony
thank you
and we have elizabeth
is it mcguigan
mcgeegan
mcguigan
thank you chairman gordon and thank you
members of the committee for the
opportunity to speak to you today about
senate bill 375 my name is elizabeth
mcguigan and i'm director of policy for
the philanthropy roundtable
now the round table is a network of
charitable donors working to foster
excellence in philanthropy and to
protect philanthropic freedom
our more than 600 members include
individual givers family foundations and
community foundations located in new
hampshire and around the country
so new hampshire is home to nearly 700
foundations that give out millions to
charitable causes each year
new hampshire's future will be brighter
if it continues to foster a friendly
environment for private charitable
organizations to help meet the needs of
its citizens enrich enrich its culture
and help solve pressing social
challenges
so this bill the charity protection act
allows new hampshire's philanthropic
organizations to fulfill their missions
without government overreach
the bill calls for any new requirements
and
c 3 corporations to first be deliberated
and approved by the legislature
excluding charitable trusts
under new hampshire statute this
protects private foundations and
charitable organizations and ensures
that the state's attorney general still
maintains full authority for regulations
over charitable trusts charitable sales
promotions and solicitations
this is a common sense reform that
honors the transparency of the
legislative process as well as your
roles as duly elected representatives
so this bill allows new hampshire's
charities to focus on advancing their
missions rather than on complying with
increased government mandates
by requiring that the state legislature
approve any new regulations or reporting
requirements on charitable organizations
this measure introduces transparency and
accountability into the regulatory
process now this is a proactive
protective bill that we feel sends a
signal to charities that new hampshire
will not overreach in the future and
that it values the strength of its
charitable sector
so why pass this bill if there's not
currently a problem with regulatory
overreach in new hampshire
the short answer is if overreach becomes
a problem in new hampshire as we've seen
in other states under future officials
it will be too late to address through
simple proactive legislation
nationwide charitable organizations are
increasingly facing calls to disclose
more details about operations governance
and grant making that do not improve
organizational effectiveness but do
increase operational and compliance
costs
some states require nonprofit
corporations to file to complete forms
with multiple agencies that often act as
repetitive and sometimes invasive
information
while there are no social benefits to
these new regulations they divert
funding away from charitable giving and
toward complying with red tape
so this bill aligns new hampshire's
governance of charitable corporations
with existing state and federal law
unless the legislature determines that
it's necessary to enact changes
this reduces the potential for unelected
officials to impose more stringent
operating requirements thereby
increasing the operational
and compliance costs on tax-exempt
organizations
so we believe philanthropy can and
should be a vital part of our
communities we've all seen the good work
that charitable organizations have done
during the pandemic and this bill will
help to protect new hampshire's
charitable sector and send a proactive
message to charities that new hampshire
is a pro-philanthropy state that values
their contributions to local communities
thank you for your consideration and
time today i'm happy to answer any
questions
bless
any questions for
mrs migwig
i
have to be honest i've never heard of
the philanthropy roundtable before so
could and just in terms of
making it new hampshire or are you to do
could you give us an example of who
might your membership be in new
hampshire
i'm not on the membership side so i
don't have specific names of our members
in the state but in general we're
private foundations community
foundations and individual givers who
care about advancing
causes that matter to the communities
representative smith
thank you thank you so much for coming
today to share this with us um i'm
looking at um your statement and um i
notice there's no address or phone
number or email and if we want to follow
up with you could you tell us where
you're based and how we get in touch
with you absolutely i'd be happy to
provide that information thank you the
committee thank you
representative horrigan did you have a
question
i apologize i missed the beginning of
your presentation um
and actually
the question was just asked was the
first one that i had but the second 501
c3s are often um
expanding their mission beyond i think
what was originally envisioned um many
groups do
what stays you know just on the farce
which isn't quite political accuracy but
very close to it and also like here in
new hampshire something as pervasive as
we use them to administer
all kinds of government programs
including for example
a very large new educational voucher
program so how
will this um bill impact uh
the state's ability to uh
first of all
um keep track of
501 c3s who are administering
governmental programs for them and also
to make sure that uh they don't cross
the line with political advocacy or
other uh activities
sure i would uh thank you for your
question i would
say that there uh
there are a couple different aspects of
the bill that i would point out the
first is that this law would not apply
to state grants or to state contracts
as well as fraud investigations or
general enforcement measures so if there
are state if there are charities that
are working with the state there is a
need for transparency if they're getting
state contracts that of course is not
covered
by this bill
to your second point about political
advocacy for example um you know i think
that is a separate question that if 501
c 3s in general are overstepping their
stated missions that is either
something that should be investigated
and enforced which is allowed under this
legislation or it could be an avenue for
further legislation to you know on the
state or even on the federal level to
say what is a 501c3 and what should they
be allowed to do
all right thanks thanks
other questions
sing then thank you for your testimony
today
and
is there anyone else who'd like to
testify
on senate bill 375.
cigna will declare the hearing closed
i obviously misjudged how much time it
would take for this hearing this morning
so
we'll be in recess until 10 30.
next hearing will be held
good morning again everyone we'll call
the house judiciary committee back to
order
our next item of business is a hearing
it's a hearing on senate bill 296.
this is a
bill relative to complaint procedures in
cases before the commission for human
rights the primary sponsor of this bill
is senator french i see that he's in
attendance and senator french would you
like to introduce your bill
good morning mr chair and to the
committee
for the record my name is harold french
i am senator from district 7 and i'm
here to introduce
senate bill 296.
i'd like to remind you all that we are
also meeting on the other side
listening to all the bills you sent us
so take that into consideration
[Laughter]
senate bill 296 is a bill about fairness
it amends rsa 354-a
so the complainant
is the only entity that can remove a
discrimination
claim to court from the human rights
commission
under current law one's employer can
force an employee to court
after finding of probable cause of
discrimination has been made by the
human rights commission
this makes the employee have to start
the process over again from scratch
i feel and many other people feel the
employee should be the only person to
decide where to pursue their claim
this bill would not impact many claims
but for those it does
the impact would be invaluable and i
would appreciate this committee's
support of this legislation thank you mr
chair
are there questions for the senator
great committee great committee
yeah i'll remember that would you come
over yeah remember that when you hear
our bills
thank you very much thank you senator
uh dave juve
who
has asked for one minute
thank you mr chair members of the
judiciary committee for the record my
name is dave giuve i am a senior vice
president at the business and industry
association which serves as new
hampshire statewide chamber of commerce
for those i know many of you are
familiar with the bia for those of you
who are not we have approximately 400
employer members with over 90 000 new
hampshire employees we are here in
opposition to this bill today and i
thought it was interesting that senator
french described this as a bill
grounded in fairness because i would
argue this bill is completely unfair
and inappropriate for new hampshire in
that we
are
choosing through this legislation to
only allow one side or one party access
to the courts in a jury
trial that seems eminently unfair to me
and so i would urge you to
at best kill this bill but i would also
recommend perhaps you might want to
consider interim study because i do
think there are issues
related to how
discrimination cases
get adjudicated in the state that are
worth looking into to see if we can
improve the process and make it fairer
and faster for all parties so mr chair i
don't know if i'm under a minute but
that concludes my testimony i would say
that there are several employment
attorneys who are here who've also
filled out pink cards who have a lot of
experience in this area i'm happy to
answer questions but they may be more uh
capable of answering than i
does anyone have any questions for mr
juve
i think you pretty much stayed within
your mouth thank you mr chair thank you
very much
and
we have
ani malakai
uh good morning
to the house judiciary committee
my name is ani malachi i'm the executive
director for the human rights commission
i don't need a lot of time to speak but
wanted to just make sure everyone knew
that i was here so that i could answer
any questions that you might have this
morning
maybe it's better to have others provide
testimony and then you call me back up
but it is
up to the beautiful smart minds that are
in this room to determine what order
you'd like to do this
i do have a handout and i'll make sure
that goes over to
representative merner and he can pass
that around to everyone
well are you
i guess if i could just ask are you
supportive of the legislation do you
what would be the consequence of passing
the legislation if you could since
it's going to affect
your organization right um so uh the the
commission is supportive of whatever the
legislature decides to do our job is to
follow the laws as so written and so
decided um and so we we don't take a
position on this
we will we will do what we're told to do
we already do have hearings there
uh potentially this could be more
but
at this point it is indeterminable
because
it's not
not sure if respondents if not allowed
to remove if they're going to
settle cases more so than having
hearings or removing them to court or if
they will stay with us and finish out
the hearing process there's no way to
know that at this point
so it would it would just it would
really depend on on what they would do
in the future
and if they remain with us then yes we
would need to have some some staffing
changes made
but those are some some of those
elements are things that we need anyway
uh just in order just to allow us to
continue to move through the caseload
that we have
representative chase
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question i'm just reading the
summary of um
the hearing in
in the senate
and
talks about you your uh testimony but it
also says under the current law
one's employer can force an employee to
court after finding probable cause and
discrimination has been made by the hrc
what what exactly does that mean that
they can force somebody to go i that's a
very good question and thank you for
that i'm not sure about forcing i know
that respondents have an opportunity to
remove a case after probable cause so i
think it depends on who's writing as to
whether it's a force
movement or removal
other questions
representative mclean
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question so what what kind
what drives people to go to the human
rights commission over going to
uh the superior court in the first place
um what's the difference that you see
that's an excellent question um the
statute so statutorily you are required
to come to the human rights commission
if you have a charge of discrimination
in the areas of employment public
accommodation and housing
or with with public education which was
added k-12 public education that was
added in 2019 so education has what's
called a true choice of forum you can
come to the hrc or you can choose to
take it to court there are opportunities
after certain steps that if the with
either party would like to remove and go
to court they have the opportunity to do
that
customarily if the complainant is
removing or the charging party is
removing they are represented by council
with our process
you don't have to have counsel
regardless of what side of the table
you're sitting on whether you're the
complainant or the respondent
so that if if the law weren't there
maybe that's a driving force but
statutorily people have to come to the
commission first to docket their charge
uh they can certainly if it's if they're
a complainant they can remove it after
docketing and go on to court and they
don't have to continue through with our
process
yep follow up
so and
you you mentioned earlier in response to
representative chase's question i think
that you didn't have the data but i just
wanted to be sure do you have any
visibility in the amount of people at
the end of the 180 days who are
removing their case to the court of
their own volition or
the the
the respondents are moving so do you
have any feel for what the breakdown is
of that
um thank you for the follow-up so
um the way this works is statutorily the
commission has two years to move through
uh the totality of a case
and the way it's written yes 180 days
you can remove
but
usually what will happen is a respondent
will typically remove after probable
cause is found because that's when they
are able to remove
however long that takes
to to get to the probable cause finding
so they're able to remove at that point
the complainant can remove at any point
so to begin the process they the a
complaint comes in in the door
and it meets the legal standard of a
charge uh parties are notified and then
after that the respondent will respond
to that charge
um
once the um
once the case is assigned to an
investigator
then the investigation takes place and
there's a finding at the end of that
whether it's probable cause or no
probable cause if there's a no probable
cause finding everything is dismissed
the case is closed however there are
appeal rights that
the
charging party has or the complaint has
if they don't agree with our finding
there are a couple of different options
that they have at that point if it's
probable cause then what happens in our
process is it moves on to a conciliation
which for the non-lawyers is really it's
mediation just after probable cause
finding so there's another opportunity
for both parties to come together and to
talk about the uh the charges and to
determine if they can make a settlement
at that point
if a settlement is not reached at the
conciliation conference then it turns
into a pre-hearing conference which
means we start to look at dates on the
calendar to be able to schedule the
hearing a hearing is scheduled but
between the
pre-hearing meeting and the actual
commencement of a hearing the parties
can still negotiate they can still talk
and potentially reach a settlement and
if they do great then the parties will
notify the commission a settlement has
been reached and then as far as we're
concerned the case is closed
other questions
representative lorenzo
thank you mr chair and thank you miss
malachi for taking my questions you know
i'm listening and looking at the
timeline on of how long it takes to
get to a conclusion on a case or to end
the case and it sounds like some of the
timelines are up to two years
okay may follow up you may so
when you have a worker for example who
is
in a workplace and they're being
discriminated against for whatever
reason it seems to me or do you think
that's a um
a
an emergency situation
um thank you for the questions uh
representative dilorenzo
it depends on on what the charge is
ultimately
what happens is we have five
investigators to investigate
cases for the entire state
there were a few more prior to 2011 and
in this upcoming budget cycle like all
state agencies i'm asking for additional
help
and so in order to not
to overburden the investigators you want
to have them have a realistic caseload
so that it's something they can actually
touch the cases and move through them a
bit more expeditiously we recently went
through our process
staff and management and looked at areas
where we could tighten timelines up
report writing is one of those things so
that we can move through the cases
i don't want to say quickly because that
seems like you're cutting corners no
corners are cut so
but timelines are tightened up right so
where someone may have had months to
send something in it's several weeks
and
since the
finishing of that conversation with
staff and coming up with a new system or
an updated system i should say
recently the assistant director and i uh
sat in on a conversation with the with
the bar uh the employment bar
and employment section of the bar excuse
me
and informed them of what that is going
to look like and you know that we're all
here wanting the same things that the
case is moved through quicker
but certainly not at uh not to the
detriment of either party because our
job at the commission is to be neutral
we're fact finders and to neutrally
in a neutral format listen to what's
happened and make a neutral
determination so
we're not favoring one party over the
other
certainly if a person has lost a job
certainly that's important and traumatic
however
even in uh
other
areas
it's not something because of the
investigation that needs to take place
and it needs to be thorough you need to
investigate you need to interview
witnesses you need to talk to the
individual or anyone that witnessed it
you have to look through and request
files to come from the respondent
and you also need to
be able to schedule everything based on
people's actual schedules
and we're able to do some things in a
virtual manner which is helpful for
complainants who may have lost income
and may not be able to could live in a
different place in the state
and may not be able to travel to our
office so we're looking at different
opportunities
and ways to connect with people so that
they have every opportunity available to
let their voice be heard
would it be great if things like this
could be done in two weeks sure but
that's not a realistic timeline because
of the the steps that have to be taken
even in a condensed timeline that have
to be taken so that it's fair to both
sides the respondent needs to be able to
answer any charge given as thoroughly as
the complainant has made their
allegations
thank you
other questions
just in terms of my understanding how
many
how many petitions or complaints do you
receive in a typical year
so
um let's see uh looking at
and this is on the federal schedule just
looking at the employment ones we have a
a work share agreement with the eeoc
who's our federal partner
so if we look at the federal fiscal year
for 2021
i believe we had a total of 242
closed cases and that's federal and
state only um but
we
and then that of course you're looking
at not just ones that were filed so i
think
for 2021 we had a total of 192 cases
file that year but then we're pulling
from the previous year to move those
forward
so
we could have anywhere from you know a
slow a slow month i use air quotes there
could be seven or eight charges that
come in that are docketed but we could
also have as many as 25 or so charges
that come in that are docketed there's
not really a rhyme or reason it's not
necessarily
it's not always slower in the summer and
busier in the winter it it just depends
representative maclean
thank you mr chair and thanks for taking
a follow-up question i mean i think it's
very important that we want to preserve
access to justice you know for everybody
that's involved in a claim
do you find
that
when
people are having their claim removed to
the superior court by the respondents do
you do you have any data of a high
incidence because of the greater
financial burden so going to the
superior court that you're seeing
in that event a lot of people just
dropping their cases do you have any
data of how many people when that
happens actually go through the whole
course of things
or versus okay i'm in superior court now
i just don't have the resources to go
forward do you have any data around that
um that's a really really good question
and i appreciate that
because the individual has removed their
well because the case has been removed
from the commission we are we do not
track it past there so what i could tell
you is you know how many have been
removed by the respondent if any how
many have been removed by the
complainant i can tell you how many
cases settled i can tell you potentially
how many in a in a calendar year have
just withdrawn meaning they went
somewhere else or they were finished
so our job is complete at that point
so i do not have any additional data
or anecdotal data no one is required to
let us know what the outcome was
so i don't have anything past the
responsibility of the commission
thank you
representative langley
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question this is a follow-up
to ms representative d lorenzo's
question
do you have any capacity to triage
complaints as they come in or you know
decide at some level that something is
so egregious that it bumps to the top of
the list and gets immediate attention or
do they all sort of
have equal attention on their way in the
front door
great question thank you for that um so
customarily what will happen is things
have equal attention
however if we realize that there's
something that wow right if a charge
comes in
we have an amazing relationship with our
client services
representatives at the department of
justice and so we could have that
conversation uh with them to determine
if if we could move if it makes sense to
move this one ahead so the difficulty
with that it's it's on both sides right
so the person if it's an egregious
situation you know
your heart and and your your sense of
justice wants to move that to the to the
top of the heap and move that through
the process however the other side of
that is the other people who are waiting
in line who may who feel as though their
claim is just as important and deserves
just as much weight and care and
adjudication and investigation so that's
a hard one
however if there's something that's just
so far out there uh we'll have that
conversation with the department of
justice to determine okay if we do this
you know we also have to look at
precedent what precedent are we setting
um and what does that look like so
that's a non-answer to your question but
that's kind of the best i can do for you
this morning thank you thank you
representative lorenzo
thank you mr chair and miss
malachi just um
a question about
the effect of the
pandemic
and if you noticed more complaints
during the pandemic thank you thank you
for that question um we did not so
complaints slowed down some during the
pandemic
um we still had them uh but they they
slowed down some
i i don't have actual numbers in front
of me but i could certainly look for
that and and send it to you okay thank
you
other questions representative simpson
thank you um i'd like to follow up on
representative maclean's question
um
you were saying that you do have the
data for how many cases are removed by
respondents and how many are removed by
complainants
and um i'd love to have that information
if you could give that to us um yes
thank you for the question i do have a
handout here so i'll give that to you
and it's just looking at 2021
because 2020 is you know the year that
never happened um and so i think 2021 is
a you know post pen sort of post
pandemic but what those numbers look
like and so what i've done um actually
is taken our chart uh on how we schedule
the hearing and and so the status of of
that particular case was whether it was
settled if who it was removed by
and then below
or in the case name information it will
say if the respondent excuse me not the
respondent but specifically if the
complainant is represented or
unrepresented
so if you see pro se cp then it just
means that they're not represented and
of course i would do that if there were
any respondents in any of these that
were unrepresented in this particular
situa for 2021 there were not but we do
have times where there are respondents
that are not represented by council and
move through our entire process up to
and including a hearing
great thank you you're welcome
representative lorenzo thank you mr just
one quick one are you an attorney i am
not
thank you okay is that good or bad
[Laughter]
well you seem to be very very well
versed in your work and i really
appreciate it well i appreciate that
thank you very much it's very
nerve-wracking sitting here you guys
there's a lot of questions i'm always
very nervous you're all nice i'm just
i'm always nervous it's like what
question will they ask will i know the
answer
[Laughter]
if
okay
other questions
you uh and i think you just answered my
my question and the the number of
complainants who are pro se and from
what i gathered there aren't very many
who
are self-represented is that true um so
uh for 2021
we had 26 hearing schedule and this is
on the document that i will give you
also if you don't want to write it you
don't have to but um so we had 26
hearings scheduled
and we usually try to schedule three per
month because excuse me because some
will settle one may go ahead someone is
removed so we just try to at least
schedule three per month
of the complainants that were
represented by council there were 18
which means that there were eight that
were unrepresented
and the total number of well all of the
respondents were represented the total
number of cases of the 26 that settled
were 11.
there were nine that were removed by
respondent and one case was withdrawn
and then we actually ended up with one
case that we heard at the commission
which was a two-day case
so the largest majority were removed by
the respondent
yes there were no there were no cases
removed by complainant
so of the 26 9 were removed by
respondent
and
if
it's common in the circuit court with
small claims in particular if people are
self-represented
and the case is worth more than fifteen
hundred dollars that respondents
frequently ask
to remove it to the superior court
because it's
more intimidating to people who are
self-represented
is that something that
you
would know of or experience in terms of
those types of claims that you're
dealing with
um thank you very much uh chair gordon
for the question um i would not
but um
if it's removed to court the opportunity
for the complainant
to have additional
fines and fees is more than with the
with the commission i'm not sure if that
answers your question
um i don't have any anecdotal data on
on that i mean we can suppose
that that may or may not be the case but
i i don't have anything definitive
um to to enlighten anyone on that topic
and i guess if i could ask one more
question that and
so basically whether they remove or not
basically what you said is that's really
for us to decide as a matter of policy
as to what we should do but
i guess the question
ultimately that i'd have is what is the
effect on the commission because
i
am already aware that just as other
people have
implied at least
that it seems to take a long time to go
through the
human rights commission typically at
least anecdotally that's what i hear
that it's a long process and longer and
many people feel maybe longer than it
should be
so
if
what is the what will be the effect if
we were to make this change
what would be the effect on the human
rights commission would
it
increase the amount of time to hear
cases
would
you need additional resources to do
cases if you could
just address the effect on your
commission
yes thank you for the question
so
what would happen initially is that we
would be scheduling more cases so right
now we're in february of 2022 we are
already scheduling hearings into the
month of december so um with
conciliations those are happening those
are at this point they're scheduled to a
week
in order to
make sure that there's time for if
there's an attorney
attorneys on both sides they have
hearing schedules they have depositions
and a wide variety of things that
they're doing so when we schedule the
conciliations at the end of a pc finding
we are taking into considerations into
consideration everyone's schedule when
we schedule the conciliations
so with that being said if everyone
remains
maybe we need to have
three per week maybe there's a little
more
i'd have to really i'd have to sit and
look at that to see if it makes sense to
do that
but if we're already scheduling into
november at this point or scheduling
into december at this point
even if
there are more conciliations we're
moving them further out
uh certainly if something settles prior
to the hearing of that particular month
people are given an opportunity to move
up if they are prepared and ready we do
offer that as an option uh but what will
happen also is cases will settle
so
um
that we we ask people to continue the
conversation uh from the beginning we
offer a free mediation program so people
have access to that it doesn't they
don't lose their place in line if the
mediation isn't productive and they can
you know they stay in um whether there's
and if it's a situation where it's
something that's a really pressing case
and the complainant doesn't want to
necessarily speak to anyone representing
the respondent but they are interested
in some form of settlement then our
investigators can do a go
and negotiated settlement there for on
behalf of the person it's really just
exchanging the information that this
person is available and interested in
settlement are you interested yes what
are your numbers great and move it
forward um so we would have to have more
we would have to at least schedule four
or five hearings per month with the
potential that maybe we'd have two per
month um given the opportunity that
people may get may settle
and with that being said um our hearing
panel is made up of three of our seven
commissioners and these are
commissioners that were not involved
with the decision with the fact finding
of the of the case and so they will
listen to a hearing which could be
anywhere from one to three four days it
depends on the complexity of the case
and so these volunteer commissioners
would need to sit and listen to this and
then deliberate and then make a
determination so
maybe um
and you know uh having additional staff
of course that's helpful so that you're
investigating more of the cases as
they're coming into the door and getting
us to a point where once it comes in and
it's docketed then hopefully being able
to assign it immediately
to an investigator to
allow that process to begin and
certainly offering mediation along the
way if that's helpful
and then we would need to have uh the
clerk to clerk the hearing so
a long answer to a short question
thank you
any other questions
representative simpson
sorry i have one more thank you
um
this is referring back to the questions
that um chairman gordon was asking and i
don't know
if this is in your
i apologize if this is in your handout
but do you know how many like
if the 8 pro se cases overlap at all
with the
nine cases that respondents
removed to the superior court
if there's any way of knowing that
um i'm not sure that i understand the
question so i was i was listening to
your numbers and you said there were
eight pro se courses or pro se cases
where the complainant represented
themselves
and then there were
nine cases where the respondents removed
the case to superior court and i was
just wondering
if you
know or
can find out whether those cases overlap
great question and
let me see i might have
so it looks like
if i'm looking at this correctly
it looks like of the nine there may have
been two
that
complainant was unrepresented
and so
of the remain of the remaining ones then
it would be that they were represented
by council
you're welcome
any other questions representative
langley
thank you mr speaker and thank you for
again taking my question i hope i can
articulate this clearly
for persons that might not be
represented
have you ever found that a case was so
egregious that you felt that they were
just poorly prepared and inadequate to
represent themselves
and defend themselves so that they would
have the need for an attorney and if so
is there some do you have some resource
that you could fall back on
to access those services for that
individual
thank you that's a really good question
um
customarily
when there's the intake process and as
cases move forward
to investigation
we do our best at the commission to
give the pro se complainant as much
information as possible but we go up to
a point because we cannot advise them
and the staff is
excruciatingly clear that we are not a
legal service in terms of providing
information on decisions that the
complainant should make
what we will do is
make suggestions and we do have a list
of if it's legal services a few of the
complainant
attorneys that practice before us we may
give them information but we make sure
that it's excruciatingly clear
a we can't give you legal advice period
full stop and that's for both parties we
do not provide legal advice we can
absolutely explain to you ad nauseam
what the law says or what your
responsibility is in terms of where we
are in the adjudication of the case
of that particular charge we can give
you as much information as you can stand
to to take in but we cannot advise you
and if the person if it appears that the
person really needs legal advice
then
the investigator if it's at that point
we'll make that
suggestion you know it sounds like you
might need some
really specialized legal advice that i
can't give you here's some names here's
some information of places you can look
this is not an exhaustive list but
here's some here's some opportunities
for you here
if the if the individual if the
complainant is still persisting with
that then it may escalate and the
assistant director may take over or if i
need to i will but usually
usually talking with the investigator
they can because they they have they
start a rapport with the individual so
usually them saying oh i can't i can't
advise you you really should seek legal
counsel on this um is where it stops but
if it needs to move further usually by
the time it's it's at the assistant
director's door she is emphatic yet
polite and calm and saying
you have to seek an attorney we cannot
advise you even if it pains us to not be
able to tell you we know what you might
what you should do maybe you know based
on the law but we cannot advise and our
staff from secretary to investigators to
paralegal very clear we cannot
give legal advice
thank you you're welcome
representative chase
i love that smile
[Laughter]
thank you
sitting here listening to all this out
of curiosity how many
ballpark calls come in that you just say
you're in the wrong department or that
that really um are just somebody that
feels that they've been
dis inherited or just
you know the word i'm trying to think of
um
but it really is not falling into what
you do does that happen often and you
have a filter for that
that's a great question i do not have
even an anecdotal number um for you but
to answer so to sort of answer the
question um yes we do so uh if in time
with the intake person their job is
really to listen and understand
uh where the person fits into our
statute um sometimes it's a it's a
situation that it's workplace bullying
right so the person is having harassment
happen but it is not based on a
protected class status so that isn't
anything that we could help them with i
mean sadly right who wants to be bullied
at work when you have to be there eight
hours a day
but that would be something that we are
pretty clear that that's not within our
statute
sometimes it's a wages and hours issue
and so we would certainly refer them to
uh to the department of labor to have
that conversation so if it's something
that is clearly not within our statute
there's a little bit of information
gathering there at the beginning for
intake
to try to determine are you in the right
place and if you're not then we do have
a book of
numbers and people that we can refer
people to so we do our best to help them
excuse me to refer them to the place
where they probably should be but if the
person is emphatic that it belongs here
there's a questionnaire they can pull it
offline fill it out and send it in and
then we can take another look
you're welcome
thank you
any other questions
you asked for two minutes of testimony i
think we're there
thank you for your testimony you're
welcome and thank everyone for their
patience
megan douglas
right
a turn
oh
okay
task one completed
uh thank you chairman thank you
committee thank you for having me here
today my name is megan douglas
i'm an attorney in private practice i
represent exclusively employees
including before the commission
and i've witnessed firsthand the problem
that this bill
would address
before i
talk a bit about the problem from my
perspective i just wanted to
refer back to testimony that director
maliki just gave
she
described referring an employee with a
wage an hour issue
or some other retaliation issue
to the new hampshire department of labor
and i think it's important for the
committee to
remember
that that employee
who doesn't have a claim that can be
addressed at the commission
but does have a claim that can be
addressed at the department of labor
that employee
has the right under our statutes
to
be heard
fully
at the department of labor and the
employer has no right of removal
so i i think that's an interesting
um comparison
to to keep in mind
um
okay the problem the fairness problem
um i hope you'll indulge me i
i used to be a a middle s a middle
school teacher and so i i tend to maybe
reduce things
complex problems to
simple concepts
um
here here is what i've come come up with
in this case
um
imagine
you're playing a board game a
complicated board game
like monopoly
and
you're playing for
a good amount of time you're making some
progress you're moving your way around
the board
you're managing some setbacks
um but you're applying the rules
you're doing what you need to do
to prevail in the game
and you get to the very end of the board
game
where you have to make the final push
to
prevail
and
to make
your
case as it were to mix the metaphor a
little bit
now imagine that your opponent
is allowed
to flip the board
and make you start all over again
and not
start all over again playing monopoly
but playing a different game
which
you may not fully understand
and which
you
may not be equipped to play
that's the fairness problem
um
i prepared a chart
uh for you
to to show you what
the
um
the board flipping
looks like
at the commission specifically and it
describes the process
that director maliki
already um
you know verbally described to you
um
in my chart
we imagine a pro se plaintiff his name
is jason
he's suffering
racial
harassment by his co-workers
he's still employed
but he has a right to file a complaint
at the new hampshire commission for
human rights to try to get some relief
so that he can continue to stay employed
without without discrimination
um so he he calls up the commission and
he asks the commission the intake worker
to take
to to take his information and the
intake worker as director malachi
describes
will
assist in the in the preparation of a
complaint albeit
simply a neutral uh recitation of the
facts as reported
and then an investigator is assigned
an investigator uh interviews jason
asks jason to produce records
asks jason to produce witnesses and it
is it is um some work
uh
then the investigator asks the employer
for
um information for witnesses for records
and sometimes the investigator has to
come back to jason and say jason what do
you think about this this evidence uh
that the employer
um submitted that says that you know we
you weren't really being criticized for
your uh religious clothing you were
being criticized because
by your co-workers because
you weren't performing very well and you
were holding the team back
and jason has to has to rebut that
at the end of this process which may
take one to two years and remember jason
is still employed trying to hold on to
his job
um
the investigator decides
you know what jason
you may not have won the monopoly game
yet
but you
do have enough
such that you might
and that's the probable cause finding
and the probable cause finding
gets communicated to the employer and
the employer says whoa wait a minute
wait a minute i have a do-over right i
play the do-over card
so i don't want to settle my case
at the commission
i don't want to have a hearing
at the commission i know
that my do-over card will make things
very challenging for jason in court
so i'm going to play it
well what happens to jason
jason quits
because he can't he can't handle this
anymore
or he has to go to court
um and his case especially if it's one
of harassment
which regrettably
you know is not um typically understood
to be a very lucrative claim he may not
be able to get an attorney who can
afford to help him
and that's not right
it's just not right
so i'll be happy to take any questions
that you have
representative chase thank you
i i
guess i didn't realize that there
weren't attorneys that were offered so
there isn't any um
like if you i've known
never really been to court to have a um
a um what is it called you know a
supplied
attorney what does it call when you if
you don't have yeah quite a thank you
court appointed chur attorney so in this
scenario there is nothing like that you
have to be able to afford an attorney in
order to
really fulfill your
your claim and your complaint correct
i just have a question and that is uh we
heard uh from mr jujube at the very
beginning about
and his argument basically is an
argument of fairness that
you should you only allow one party to
appeal shouldn't both parties have that
opportunity i guess the question i have
for you is
should either party be what if you
took the legislation and said neither
party
each party is going to be required
to accept the decision of the human
rights commission
i think that's what
sb 296 would do
i think
it would uh
establish that if probable cause
is found
at the commission to which is a you know
a uh
it's a preliminary finding
that the plaintiff
um has a case has has merit
that the plaintiff therefore gets to
elect to
stay at the commission or or move to
court
but the the defendant the employer
does does not have the ability to
remove to court aft
after the pc finding
well if i could just but
but still
the complainant has the ability to
remove the case to the superior court if
they want to at that time so
what if neither party were able to do
that they have to abide by whatever the
final decision of the civil rights
commission um
well
um frankly i
i've been thinking about this bill
through the lens of the pro se plaintiff
um i
i i
um
frank i don't see any issue with a
plaintiff
trying the matter
before a neutral body
that is the commission that's i believe
seven commissioners appointed by the
governor i have no reason to think that
the the the decision by the new
hampshire human rights commission would
be any
less any more biased or
less valid or legitimate um or accurate
or just
than a jury
um as i as i've um alluded to at the
beginning of my testimony a
whistleblower can try their case fully
at the department before a single
hearing officer
at least at the commission you've got a
body
of people who have to
come to the same conclusion
thank you
other questions representative lorenzo
thank you mr chairman and thank you
attorney douglas for taking my uh
question um now do you practice in any
other states
no i don't
um okay may i follow up yep are you
familiar with the mass commission
against discrimination in their
process could you repeat that okay are
you familiar with the mcad in their
practice in um
massachusetts i i'm not
i'm sorry i've i've practiced
exclusively here in new hampshire okay i
have just one more so how would you
compare um new hampshire's process with
the federal process
um for instance e eoc
yeah the eeoc um
new hampshire
the new hampshire commission for human
rights
in my experience over the last 12 years
better investigates the charges before
before it
then the eeoc
um
we
prefer to we have the option in um in
most discrimination cases
of filing at the eeoc
or the new hampshire commission for
human rights
or
or both
we usually file uh
bull at both um but electing to have the
commission
investigate
the
the uh the charge because they do a
better job
in my experience
other questions
seeing them thank you for your testimony
today thank you thank you very much
james
is it reedy
good morning good morning
thank you for the opportunity to speak
um i'm a uh
management side lawyer i represent
employers and i uh the uh i work at she
infinibas in green in manchester
i'm the chair of the firm's labor and
employment group i've been in practice
for 33 years
and
i think it's fair to say that i've had
hundreds of cases before the new
hampshire commission
and i speak in opposition to this bill
i want to start off by saying however
that
i truly appreciate the efforts of the
commission
and what they're charged to do
and executive director malachi and i'm
not trying to curry favor
even though i do have many cases up
there
she's done an exceptional job at trying
as she said to streamline the process
and move things along
she also mentioned that
the under statute and under the fepa
which is a a cooperative agreement with
the eeoc
what case is a dual filed
as attorney douglas just referenced
the new hampshire commission has an
agreement where they investigate on
behalf of the eoc
and it's within two years and as a
funding exchange in that regard
sadly because the staff the staffing of
the
agency as such
and the funding is such that cases don't
move through the system in two years
they don't move this through the system
typically in three years i just had a
case with the decision it was filed in
five years
and
justice delayed is justice denied
in many regards and i heard a lot of
comments and questions in that regard
um
one quick comment also with regard to
the department of labor because i'm a
frequent flyer there
uh
that you have if you have a wage claim
you can file it either it before the new
hampshire commission i'm sorry before
the department of labor or in superior
court either party can do that
and uh and then there's appeal rights to
the superior to the supreme court
um
in essence
my testimony is focused on one thing and
that is fairness mr juve mentioned that
others have mentioned that as well
by taking away the respondents ability
to remove this matter
uh after a probable cause finding and i
want to talk about that in a second
uh is effectively unfair because the
complainant can remove it after 180 days
before the commission and in my
experience
sometimes do
but remember a lot of these cases are
taken on a contingent fee basis and it
make it's more cost effective to leave
it before the commission
um there was there are comments earlier
about
the cost of going to court going to
court a plaintiff typically will be on a
contingent fee basis it's on an hourly
basis like on the other side
but it is effectively it would be uh
lopsided one side where one party can
remove a court and the other could not
and remember a probable cause finding
doesn't mean an absolute it means 51
percent by a preponderance of the
evidence so what is a proponent of the
evidence it could be based upon written
submissions and in recent years there
have been cases and this is not a
criticism or disparagement of the the
commission investigators sometimes they
don't get to invest to to talk to the
witnesses i've had that in several cases
they base it on written submissions
they're absolutely overwhelmed and while
there was a pause or a delay with covid
on average the commission receives uh
more than 200 charges a year
so if there's a delay in the system
referencing what um executive director
malachi said
i think there would be a burden further
on the commission you're not going to
expedite cases it's going to push it out
even further so take that case that's
been there for five years and then
sitting down for a hearing
no benefit to either party in that
regard and in in my case or in cases
that we've had you've got witnesses that
either relocate or memories fade and the
like
this bill would not improve that system
at all at all and if there is an
opportunity to improve the system there
many ways and i know that that's been
looked at and there have been there's
been progress this bill would not do
that
in fact with regard to the hearing
process before the commission
my estimation is as i looked at the
record since 1974 there have been 76
hearings before the commission so in
nearly 50 years
76 hearings
that's not a lot and the other is
we appreciate the fact that the
commissioners are indeed volunteers
but they're not lawyers and they're not
judges they're lay people goodly people
good professionals but they're they
don't have the uh the the um formality
that you might have in court rules of
evidence uh and the like and going
through the system
um
again hundreds of cases filed
the statute says three years again some
older
uh
i think the um
under the current system the system
effectively works if there's a pc
finding yes it's not being forced you
have the opportunity to remove the
matter to court and it's a de novo
hearing if this bill were successful
there would not be a de novo hearing
meaning start over again or have a fresh
look at the evidence it would be based
on the uh errors of law and that's a
very narrow field so um effectively
uh and i think it was the reference from
from
mr jave earlier is i think that
more time and based upon the many
questions today i think more time is
taken to send this back to
if if the bill were not killed going to
interim study committee to consider this
further there's a lot to unpack here
talking about the process how it a
charge is filed how it's investigated
the hearing process and some of the
statistics that were referenced earlier
i have a lot of anecdotal evidence but
i'm not going to take up any of your
time in that regard
just based upon my experience i think
while perhaps this was well intended i
think it would actually clog the system
much more and it would also take away
the fairness that we referenced earlier
one last point
there's a constitutional argument here
when you have state and federal claims
filed before the commission if the
commission
under this proposed uh system issued an
uh a probable cause finding and you had
to go before the the commission for a
public hearing
what about the federal claim that
they're also investigating that claim if
there's a probable cause finding you
have 90 days to file in federal court
and start over again
and that is a de novo hearing in that
process so you would have a
constitutional problem with with uh the
state law claim effectively being
adjudicated and the federal clock claim
often the same claim just under two
different statutes
having a a fresh look so
again that could be a delay in the
system
questions for attorney reedy
represent mclean
thank you mr chair so um
even if
resources could be applied to accelerate
the process
and
we were
to eliminate across the board removal um
for uh after finding a probable cause
you there you still have
problems with the mechanism even then
because of
access to the courts beyond that
is that correct so even if we were to to
do those amendments to to streamline and
to address the resource concerns and to
make the removal fair across the board
you still have concerns with the
mechanism thanks for the question but
just to be clear when you say
streamlined to make it fair across the
board are you saying neither party can
remove or both parties can remove
so resource issues to accelerate the
process because you talked about i
brought in a claim in 2017 is just being
resolved now
so that resource issues on the one side
um and also basically yes exactly nobody
can remove it after a probable cause
hearing including the claimant so if
those
if the
legislation was amended to basically
address those two things my
understanding you still have concerns
with the mechanism on other
constitutional grounds etc that's
correct and i think i would summarize it
this way the right to jury trial the the
hearing before the commission would not
be a jury trial and that doesn't again
not to not to be critical of the
commissioners in the public hearing
process but you you should have a right
to a jury trial and then uh the other is
uh under the if you have a dual filing
you would have that right under the
federal system and you would have a
conflict between state and federal law
and there'd be a question as to whether
or not there was any any any uh whether
or not the state law decision could be
entered into evidence in the federal
and i have at least one federal court
decision where this says there is no
prohibitive value that the the federal
court did not accept the because of the
highly prejudicial nature of uh of the
of a probable cause finding and it was
you have the right to start over again
thank you thank you
so yeah can i just ask how long
on the on the average
from your experience does it take to get
from the time of a filing of a complaint
to a probable cause finding
uh at a minimum
thanks for a question at a minimum at
least three years uh more like in recent
years closer to four and or perhaps more
and if i could just follow up so
so it that it seems difficult
to accept at least that somebody has to
wait
three years to get to a probable cause
finding
and
having done so gotten to that point then
making a decision to remove it to
another venue
and
is it possible that
the parties could elect to go to the
superior court at an earlier point in
the process not waiting until you get to
that point well that's what the
complainants have right now after 180
days before the commission so six months
they can remove the matter to federation
to uh state court uh they could actually
move them out of to federal court as
well um
so why why not apply the same standard
to
the
the the subject of the complaint the
respondents i i would applaud that if
you have that opportunity again because
under the under the system in uh the
hampshire department of labor whether
it's a whistleblower or a wage claim
you have the opportunity to elect
to be to go to the department of labor
or to superior court
i'm just relating it to small claims
cases because i'm a small claims judge
but basically you have a limited period
if you want to remove to the superior
court you have a limited period of time
to do that up front as opposed to
you don't make a finding and then decide
to remove it to the court and get it in
oval here right department of labor you
you've got within the statute to to file
your claim
under the discrimination statutes before
the new hampshire commission for human
rights and the eeoc you've got 180 days
from the last event of discrimination to
file the claim or if you're filing both
under federal and state law you've got
300 days so 10 months
at a maximum to file your claim and then
it once filed with the commission in a
dual filing you've got 180 days as a
complainant to remove that matter to
court that was that's after 180 days so
anytime after 100 days you can remove
that matter there's no maximum you can
do it by this point
because you've already filed with the
commission
thank you other questions representative
horrigan um
what percentage of the uh is it these
respondents that you're uh that you're
working uh working for they typically
um
companies that have um
internal procedures in place to deal
with uh
conflicts in the workplace um either
because they're a larger organization
and or the
workers have a union or otherwise
protected or these
mostly things where everything is
informal and they kind of comes out of
the blue for the respondent and then
they have to go
over and hire hire you to get them out
of the uh
deal with the complaint which i would of
course applaud but um
the um
the area of employment law workplace law
since the time i started practicing in
1989 has evolved significantly
gone are the days of the wild wild west
where you're just an at-will employee
you have no rights you think of the
litany of of employment laws on a state
and federal level that have been adopted
since 1990 and they're significant with
that employers have responded by having
whether it's in a union environment a
non-union environment public sector
private sector large or small with early
resolution the law calls for prompt and
appropriate investigation and resolution
of disputes so uh an employer would be
foolhardy if it didn't have that process
it takes a lot in this economy to uh
recruit and retain talent uh and that's
not just true in this economy it's in
any economy so
you want to make certain that your your
workplace is functioning properly but
the law calls for that and uh and so
in my experience whether we're talking
about a small
family held business or a large
multinational corporation they all have
those procedures in place are they
foolproof well clearly not because
people still aren't may not be satisfied
with the result
and and they have the opportunity to
file
at the federal level at the state level
other questions representative lorenzo
thank you mr human and thank you for
taking my question
um
you know we talked about the process
and at the end of the process it's a
volunteer board that makes the decisions
would you consider that a strength or a
weakness of the program
can i say i feel strongly both ways
um i i just appreciate the the um the
the commissioners that volunteer their
time they're all professionals that
volunteer their time and their skill
sets to uh looking at cases when they
can but otherwise there's also an
investigating commissioner someone who
wouldn't be a part of a public hearing
who
looks at the investigation and makes
suggestions until a decision whether
it's probable cause or no probable cause
uh is issued so
i think there's a benefit to the
commission certainly uh uh yeah there
are ways to improve yes i think that the
improvements would be focused on as
executive director malachi said uh at
the intake and investigation process and
that would be the resources that we
talked about earlier um but the
from my perspective i think the
hearing process i in a case i have i can
proceed to public hearing if my client
if it makes sense in that regard
or we can go to court so we have that
choice and it's it's on a facts and
circumstances basis but um so
as i said there have been some 76
hearings over the last 48 years so
parties do elect and including employers
don't remove the court and they go to
before the so there's that option
available
my position is that option should remain
okay other questions
thank you for your testimony thanks so
much appreciate your three to five
minutes max
and samantha
is at
hewning thank you chairman gordon
opportunity to talk to you today you
need to get next to the microphone
apologies thank you chairman gordon and
committee members for this opportunity
to talk with you today my name is
samantha hearing i'm an attorney
practicing at douglas leonard and garvey
in concord new hampshire a large portion
of my practice is plaintiff's employment
law so we represent the employees
i want to focus you in on two points
we've heard a lot of stuff today but i
just want to boil it down to fairness
and state resources those are the most
important things that we have to talk
about today
um a question was raised why not
eliminate the ability of both parties to
remove why not just keep everybody at
the commission and let them live with
what the commission decides
i want to answer that by telling you how
we got here in the first place
354 when the original removal provision
was put in it was added because
sometimes plaintiffs have claims that
the hrc cannot hear
for example wrongful termination claims
and so
what would happen in a case where an
employee has a claim that's subject to
the hrc's process but it also cannot be
heard there they would go through the
process at the hrc they would then have
to file the separate claim in court
the result of that is telling the hrc
and the court the same set of facts the
same set of witnesses
really trying the case twice just to
bring two claims so to eliminate that
waste of resources
we put in the removal provisions so that
plaintiffs can remove their case to
court because they have an attorney who
says to them look we're going to
litigate this case twice we might as
well just remove let's make this more
efficient for everybody
that's how we got here so if we
eliminated that removal right for the
complainant i feel that we would be
wasting our state's resources by
having cases litigated at the hrc that
could just move through the court system
and we would be clogging up the hrc
um
i also want to note briefly no one
testified against this bill in the
senate
it was passed by voice vote on consent
calendar
and i want to talk about the fairness
issue
the united states supreme court long ago
held that people who bring claims
against someone else
it's their right to decide the forum
that here that hears their claim it's a
long-standing principle in this country
i also want to talk about the resource
differential between employer and
employee
so we've been talking about
the data today
2015-2021 in a seven-year period there
were
28 times that the respondent removed the
case to court after the cause finding
so
i can't tell you what happened in each
of those 28 cases but i can tell you
what i see the potential to have been
which is that you have somebody like
john who's a bus boy at a restaurant
he's sexually harassed by owner number
one he goes to owner number two and he
complains and he says please help me fix
this i just want to work i don't want
this guy touching me while i'm just
trying to do my job and clear tables
owner number two doesn't care and
nothing happens the harassment continues
john either has to keep going to work
and endure the sexual harassment
or
he could decide you know what i'm going
to do something about this i'm going to
file the human rights commission
john quits his job he files at the human
rights commission he looks for an
attorney to take his case and he gets a
new job three weeks later at a new
restaurant
now john's problem is that when he calls
an office like mine
i can't take his case because i i have
to get paid
john makes a low wage as a busboy so he
can't afford to pay my hourly rate
the other problem for john is that he
with with three weeks of wage losses and
as a low wage earner to begin with
he's not going to have the type of wages
that would allow me to recover my fees
on a contingency contingency fee basis
so john's gonna have to do this without
an attorney he goes through the
commission process
he convinces the commission that owner
number one was touching him while he was
trying to clean tables and he gets a
probable cost finding but the owners
don't want to deal with this so they
removed to court hoping like attorney
douglas testified that this will make it
too difficult for john to continue it'll
make him start over
john does give up he's got to go to
college he doesn't have time to deal
with this he doesn't have the knowledge
or the resources
what i want to i want to focus not just
on the fairness to john issue but i want
to ask
you representatives what message are we
sending to employers
if we allow them to do that to employees
like john
if we give them a sort of
you know trump card at the end of the
game that they can play to just get
themselves out of trouble
um i also want to talk
talk about um
the employers the employer's ability to
remove the case doesn't somehow make it
more difficult for the employer
regardless of which forum the employer
is in they still have a duty
to
plead
the employee still has a duty to plead
their claims by preponderance of the
evidence regardless of the forum
so eliminating the employer's ability to
remove doesn't change that they still
have that the employee still has the
same burden
there was a question earlier from
representative dilorenzo i believe who
asked
what about people who have something
very egregious happen to them
is it possible that these pro se people
could give up because they can't go to
court and they don't have the resources
to deal with this
in my experience outside of the small
claims arena plaintiffs are not equipped
to represent themselves in litigation
and that's not to say anything negative
about the ordinary citizen but it's just
to emphasize
the complex process that is filing a
claim in court and taking it to the end
i also want to talk about some
opposition testimony that i heard today
at one point i heard testimony that an
employer can remove wage and
whistleblower claims from the department
of labor
that's false there is no ability for the
employer to remove those claims
i also heard testimony that
keeping a case at the commission and
scheduling it for a hearing will just
push the resolution at the commission
out farther it'll just keep the timeline
going
that's ignoring the reality of the
timeline that we experience in court
which doesn't fare much better than the
commission's timeline
so
keeping it at the commission and waiting
for the commission's ability to give you
a hearing or moving to court and
starting over from scratch
keeping it at the commission is not
going to extend that if anything the
timeline of the case is going to be
extended by
putting it into suit and starting the
process over there's a new complaint
there's a new answer there's a new
schedule for the case there are new
people to be questioned there are new
questions to be answered it's all from
scratch
i also want to talk about the
constitutional argument about the right
to a jury trial
um
our own new hampshire supreme court
decided that the constitutional
right to a jury trial does not attach to
legal rights that didn't exist back in
1794 when our constitution was passed
in 1794 we didn't have 354a or the human
rights commission meaning there is no
constitutional right to a jury trial for
those claims that would be heard at the
commission
i think i think uh representatives that
concludes all of the points that i
wanted to make but i'm happy to accept
your questions
questions representative chase it's not
really a question i just like i missed
your name and where you are from
samantha hearing i work with douglas
leonard and garvey in concord thank you
very much thank you
any other questions
representative lorenzo thank you mr
chair and thank you um attorney um
i'm going to ask you the same question
that i asked the previous speaker and i
wanted to get your take on um
the
human rights commission's process that
ends in
volunteers making a decision um i'd like
to hear your take on that thank you
i don't have any issue with volunteer
and i apologize i can't see very well
around this
but
i don't have any problem with volunteers
making a decision at the end because the
volunteers are provided with the
framework of the law that applies as
long as that's provided then i think
that volunteers can adequately make a
decision if they've been presented with
the relevant evidence
thank you
any other questions
but if i could just uh
uh the
and as has already been mentioned
justice delayed is justice denied and
is there
just in terms of looking at the
legislation is there a way of allowing
both parties to make an option to go to
the superior court instead of the human
rights commission earlier in the process
as opposed to
after a probable cause finding has been
made
i suppose it would be possible to do
that um
i i believe as the
the last uh speaker said
at 180 days the uh the complainant can
remove to court it's possible that the
statute could be amended to give
respondents that same ability
i think what we're still going to
experience in that case is a resource
differential between the parties
when we have
small
employees who don't have a lot of wages
can't get a lawyer versus a company who
even if a mom-and-pop shop has some more
resources at their disposal than that
employee
by by forcing the employee into court
or even earlier in the process denies
the employee from pursuing claims that
we've decided
um are warranted under our laws
right
and if i could just so
so and i get the issue that uh the human
rights commission is something that may
may be more user-friendly particularly
to pro-save litigants
and
less intimidating than going to the
superior court
so i get i get that
um
and i get the idea that
you wait to a probable cause hearing
which might be from what i understand
out three years
and then the employer or respondent
at that point in time has the ability to
basically have a de novo process
so
which
just seems to delay everything so what
if
what if
the parties uh if you wanted if
once once you file the human rights
commission the complainant is committed
to be at the human rights commission
they can't remove
but you give
the employer the right to say that if
within 90 days after having received a
complaint you have the right to have it
removed to the superior court
for a jury trial or whatever else
instead of that whole three-year delay
would that be something that would be
more fair
i think that
see i
my issue representative is that i don't
see a lack of fairness for the employer
here
because
the new hampshire supreme court has held
that they're not entitled to that jury
trial in court anyway
and because the united states supreme
court has held that the person who files
the claim is the person who has the
right to decide which forum hears it not
the other way around so i don't i don't
see the fairness issue based on our
court's precedence
um
but that's something that certainly the
stat that could happen the statute could
be amended in the fashion that you
suggest i would again come back to
the unfairness that would result to
people who can't get an attorney to
handle their claims
and it's it's
it's less about uh court being
intimidating and more about just
i'll be candid i'm a new attorney i
still don't know everything that i'm
doing
i still have to ask my colleagues daily
for assistance with the litigation
process
i can't imagine
not having the education and background
and assistance that i have and trying to
proceed through this process without all
that it would be impossible
um the other thing i want to emphasize
too is that one of the great advantages
of the human rights commission to
employers is that the process is
confidential
you don't have to experience bad
publicity for claims that may be without
merit
you can keep things confidential at the
commission and let things be decided
there
it's also informal easy to deal with
and very very cost effective compared to
court
thank you
any other questions
saying then thank you for your testimony
today thank you
uh beth derrick
i was just checking to see if i was
going to say good morning or good
afternoon but we're still in the morning
good morning everyone my name is beth
daragon i'm an attorney an employment
law attorney at pass story crayons in
concord new hampshire and for the record
i'm from boston
i always like to note that
so i
i'm not going to spend a lot of time
repeating the testimony that's gone
forward but i would like to spend a
little bit of time clarifying some of
the remarks that have been made for a
start i think it might be helpful for
you to know that i represent both
employees
and employers
have done so for about 16 years so
currently
i was trying to tally the number in my
head but i think currently at the
commission for human rights i have an
equal number of clients who are on the
complainant side and an equal number who
are on the respondent's side
so i can uh you know at least give you
what i like to think is a well-balanced
view
of
representation of both in the same forum
in the process
i uh testify here today in opposition to
this bill
and my biggest issue
is that this denies
the jury
process
to my respondent clients
so to my respondent clients who are the
recipients of a charge of discrimination
and ask me okay beth now what's going to
happen what's the process here
currently i'll say to them well
we will stay at the commission and have
to stay at the commission until there's
a probable cause or no probable cause
finding as you've heard earlier today
and then they say and then what happens
well at that point we have a choice we
can proceed with a hearing at the
commission
or
we can remove to court
now to my complainant clients
ask me the same question beth what's the
process
well
um here's the process after 180 days
because cases as you've heard are
pending at the commission for a lengthy
period of time and that's no criticism
of the commission i interned at the
commission as a law student and had was
one of those intake
um folks who had to listen to the the
types of folks who were calling in and
asking whether or not they had
uh viable claims so uh my heart is
always there at the commission i'm
actually a mediator as well for the
commission for human rights site so i
wear many hats but for my complainants
i can say
okay well after 180 days we've reached a
juncture
we can decide
whether or not we want to file in court
and avail ourselves
of
typical discovery practices
right depositions interrogatories
requests for production of documents
can and is it worth us to avail
ourselves as though on the complainant
side oftentimes it is because the
complainants
don't have
the records
right the employer has the records
oftentimes strategically it is a good
idea to remove we want to understand
what the employer has we want to know
what records they have what emails what
text messages
how else are we going to get them how
else am i going to assess the case
sometimes strategically it is worth
making that move
but my complainants
have the right and opportunity to do
that and they have the right to be heard
in front of a jury of their peers and to
have the case adjudicated applying the
rules of evidence
my respondent clients if this bill were
to go into law
would lose that ability they have no
right to a jury trial they have no right
to be heard by their peers they have no
right to a strict application of the
rules of evidence
that's a huge disparity in my view i
represent both sides i'm looking at it
from both sides but as an attorney i
have a big issue
with one side
being denied equal equal justice before
the law and to be able to be heard by a
jury of their peers i just want to make
a a couple of
points
attorney reedy earlier
specified and stated about the new
hampshire department of labor process in
regard to wage claims
the
filing party can elect whether or not to
file at the new hampshire department of
labor or in superior court that's an
election that that can be made it's not
a removal
issue that's that's not the statement
that he made
so that
for those reasons i'm opposed to the
bill i want to see both parties be able
to make informed decisions strategic
decisions that are based on
their own considerations and be able to
be heard by a jury of their peers if
they so choose and i thank you very much
for your time i am still well within my
15 minutes and i'd be happy to answer
any questions
hey are representing mclean
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
one of the
one of the things at the core of uh
attorney hearings support behind the
bill she was just talking a lot about
the resource delta
that exists between the the employer
and the claimant and and she stressed
that in many cases it might not even be
possible for a claimant to be able to
get representation and she kind of went
through the arguments for why that would
be so
you however represent an equal balance
of employers and claimants um
in in the in the case that she brought
forth where i have a busboy who is
very
uh
low compensation
is there any claimant within your
clientele that would is at that level or
i'm just trying to get a feel to to
understand the weight of that argument
for the resources
thank you for the question
so um
damages that can be awarded
under title 7 and under 350 4a don't
only include lost wages and future lost
wages it also includes compensatory
damages
so that when an attorney is assessing
the viability of a claim and i'd be
happy to take the the prior example of
the busboy who was assaulted essentially
at work right he was inappropriately
touched
er
that and and most likely
suffered emotional distress damages as a
result it may be true that he doesn't
make a lot of money it may be true that
the lost wages calculation is low but
you know what could be high
the compensatory damages that's
egregious conduct when someone touches
someone inappropriately and if there are
enough facts and evidence to support
that
then um
i
i question whether or not there is an
attorney in the state of new hampshire
who would who would shy necessarily not
take that case just based on lost wages
and um
but that gives me an opportunity to give
you a real life example too so years ago
when i was at upton in hatfield and i
was a new lawyer there
a client came in who had a no probable
cause finding from the commission
and she was pro se
she came in and spoke with heather burns
who was a partner and is to this day at
the firm and pitched her case to us we
took the case
no probable cause finding she was a pro
se client took the case went to federal
court and we prevailed
and so um i give that as an example
because it is not all doom and gloom we
do have real cases and real examples of
pro se
pro se litigants being at the commission
even getting a no probable cause finding
in their attorneys who will assess the
case on the merits and make um judgment
calls about the viability of those
claims
thank you
representative horrigan
um thank you very much um
and i could say i missed the beginning
of your presentation what your name was
bertha what dario close beth daragon
just not dragon just a theory
one letter makes a difference yes you
have a lifetime experience you've played
you've got to spell your name like um
when the um
so when you're
if you're working for a responding
client and they come to you are they
typically surprised that this complaint
is you know come across their desk and
uh or
or are they typically something where
there's been a
long-running conflict in the workplace
and other avenues internal avenues have
been explored and um didn't work out
it's a mixed bag
you know thank you it's a mixed bag
sometimes um
sometimes where it's a client who i have
represented through a complaint and
internal complaint process
and they've conducted an investigation
and so forth
there's still the possibility that when
the client leaves the workforce they
still might file a charge of
discrimination and those instances it's
you know we receive notice of the charge
and say oh
you know we thought you know that was
all handled well and whatever but um we
know where that's coming from but then i
have clients who
are just you know they had no idea that
this was coming and
um the person hadn't raised any issues
in the workplace and the first they hear
a bit is
in a charge that's been filed
and the other point i wanted just to
make it occurred to me in terms of
cost to the employer i do think it's
important to understand the insurance
piece of this
not
i there may be a misunderstanding or a
misapprehension that employers all have
coverage for these types of claims
insurance coverage
it's not covered under their general
liability practice coverage unless they
have a separate employment liability
program coverage insurance program they
don't have insurance for the claim i
have several clients now
where they do not have insurance
coverage i have one client now does have
insurance coverage the deductible is 75
000.
so that's not really coverage so
um so i just i want to raise that
because there there is a cost to the
employer they're not all covered by
insurance and even if they are covered
by insurance
oftentimes there is a sizable deduction
that has to be met
are there any other questions
seeing none thank you thank you very
much just just a hint when you ask for
15 minutes to testify sometimes you get
called last so oh
there was i did receive one additional
card and that's from marissa chase
good afternoon representatives i don't
like
being between you and your lunch um for
the record my name is one minute i did
my name is marissa chase for the record
i'm the executive director of the new
hampshire association for justice a
statewide professional association of
trial attorneys um both megan douglas
and samantha herring are members of our
organization and we requested this bill
be introduced by senator french
samantha mentioned um we had not heard
of any opposition to this bill this
session um there was no testimony in
opposition in the senate i had not
received any indication that um
you know this this had opposition so i'm
a little surprised today
um
but
as always we are willing to work with
stakeholders if there can be a
compromise i don't know that that's
possible on this issue but mr chair you
know i like to try
in new hampshire i just want to point
out one thing that attorney daragon said
you know in new hampshire we experience
conservative juries it's overwhelmingly
common that emotional distress damages
um that mragon spoke of
for the busboy example are not given
weight by our juries one mechanism for
judging the amount of emotional distress
damages is by
looking at lost wages so
again i think i've said this before
probably a hundred times to some of you
in new hampshire these cases are taken
by contingency fee that means that the
lawyer just fronts all the costs of
litigation and does not get paid by the
client until and unless they prevail
that is an enormous risk assessment that
lawyers especially a small firm have to
make
so
a lot of our plaintiff's attorneys i can
tell you on our list serve where we have
over 500 members
that talk about these issues there's an
employment law practice group in the
state as well called neela
the overwhelming amount of plaintiff's
lawyers in this state do unfortunately
turn away many complainants and we do
see a lot of pro se litigants
that are removed to superior court after
a probable cause finding at the human
rights commission that that give up i
mean that is the experience of our
members i'd be happy to try to find you
know specific data numbers on that but i
can tell you that that's
something i hear frequently
other questions
see none thank you for your testimony
today thank you enjoy your lunch is
there anyone else who would like to
testify on senate bill
296 seeing no one we will declare the
hearing closed and thank you everyone
for testifying today
and we'll recess the committee will be
in recess till one o'clock
okay we'll call the house judiciary
committee back to order
our next
item on our agenda today is a hearing
it's a hearing on senate bill 302
establishing the personal privacy
protection act
and
and the primary sponsor of this bill is
senator birdsall and
senator would you like to introduce your
bill
thank you committee
thank you mr chair
for the record my name is regina bartel
state senator
state senator for district 19 which is
which encompasses the towns of
uh derry
hampstead and windham
and i am the prime sponsor of senate
bill 302
um
the objective of
the objective of 302 is basically
sorry i have the wrong
list um
was basically to
make sure that donors names are
kept private
and um
this comes on the heels of
one
supreme court decision that was made
recently in
um
afp versus bonta and also in 19 i
believe it was a 1956
u.s supreme court decision
with the naacp
and basically what it does is it
protects the donors
and of those on 501c3s
it does not impact any
elect
election
um
bills so
sorry
i lost my um my list
but um this is this bill is um virtually
it's a very bipartisan we have uh the
aclu in favor of it we have um
the afp we have
the
coalition of domestic violence
is in favor of this
and there are a
long list of
organizations that are actually in favor
of this
so
with that i will
end my testimony
no um you are there any questions for
senator birdsall
representative simpson
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question senator um
do you have a copy of that list that you
could share with us either now or over
email that'd be helpful i do great
thanks
other questions
there will be other uh individuals
behind me that can be a little bit more
detailed on the um the piece of
legislation
representative horgan did you have a
question um we have
we have many 501c organizations
administering state programs um
perhaps most famously the new
educational uh
freedom account program so how does
what does this bill do to
protect the uh taxpayers right to make
sure that the money that these 501cs are
expending is uh expended properly
well i think that uh question can be
answered with someone from behind me
thank you well thank you
any other questions
seeing them thank you senator thank you
diane quinlan
good afternoon i have written testimony
would you like me to present us now
yes if you just give it to
representative merner and he'll make
sure it gets circulated
mr chair members of the committee my
name is diane quinlan i'm the assistant
director of charitable trust at the
attorney general's office
and i'm here to express our opposition
to senate bill 302
we recognize that one of the purposes of
senate bill 302 was to encourage
philanthropy
it's a goal that our office shares
but we are concerned that this bill
would actually have the opposite effect
the bill would mean less transparency in
the governance of charitable
organizations
and will make it more difficult for our
office to fulfill our oversight
responsibilities so that donors can have
more confidence that their donations are
used for their intended purposes
when i'm going to be brief because i've
submitted written testimony but when
considering this bill
it's important to note that the ultimate
beneficiary of charitable nonprofits is
the public and the public therefore has
an interest in them and the attorney
general's responsibility to protect the
public's interest in charitable
organizations is grounded in common law
well before 1943 when the legislature
enacted a law establishing the director
of charitable trusts as an office that's
wholly dedicated to the oversight of
charitable trusts and charitable
organizations
it's also important to note that the
vast majority of members of governing
boards of charitable non-profit
corporation organizations are volunteers
while the bill was amended in the senate
to allow our office to request the names
of board members in annual reports
the bill as amended would not allow our
office to request the names of board
members in connection with the
registration process when charities
register with our office
this is a time when we're often able to
catch and can address things like
conflict of interest transactions
pecuniary benefit transactions and
address issues regarding whether or not
the board is
composed
in accordance with
state law
this bill would also prohibit other
public agencies from requesting the
names of volunteer board members and
would prohibit all public agencies
including our office
from disclosing those names in public
reports
in assurances and discontinuances in
lawsuits and in connection with
right-to-know requests
in the past year we had a case that
would have been negatively impacted by
this bill
the case involved an organization that
purportedly was formed to support breast
cancer patients and their families and a
married couple who served as volunteer
board members the president and the
treasurer
after we received an anonymous tip that
the charity was a scam and that the
president and treasurer were using the
funds for their own personal purposes
we attempted to contact the charity on
numerous occasions by telephone by mail
by email and we issued two
administrative subpoenas in accordance
with
rsa 724 but the board members failed to
respond to any of those efforts
we subsequently brought a lawsuit
against both the charity
and the couple
and when we did that we issued a media
release
the media release which named the
president and treasurer effectively
stopped the fundraising for the charity
and we received from the public a number
of calls with information about those
two individuals that we were able to use
in connection with our court case
that information
was
provided to the court and ultimately the
court
issued a judgment shutting down that
sham charity and holding those two
individuals accountable
senate bill 302 would also prohibit
public agencies from requesting the
names of donors and for making them
public first our office does not
routinely ask for the names of donors we
don't need it and we don't ask for it
that's unlike in other states but we do
not routinely ask for it but there are
times when we do need the names of
donors for example when we're trying to
provide restitution to donors we need
that information
also when we are enforcing charitable
gift restrictions in uh charitable
trusts or in uh testamentary
gifts like in in wills we need to file
uh we may have to file a petition in
court under the terms of this bill we
would have to file those petitions under
seal
so we believe that senate bill 302
addresses a problem that really doesn't
exist in new hampshire and it would be
detrimental to the legislature's stated
goal in the voluntary corporation act of
encouraging in charitable nonprofit
corporations a quote connection with the
public
and quote public confidence
for these reasons we urge the committee
to report senate bill 302 as inexpedient
to legislate or in the alternative to
refer to the bill to further study i'd
be happy to answer any questions
questions
represent horrigan
i don't know if you can answer
answer this but i'll ask the same
question i answered
ask
senator birdsall a few minutes ago which
is uh
how would this bill impact the uh
state government's ability to monitor
501cs which administer state programs i
guess i specifically
mentioned the controversy new
educational freedom account program but
there's probably dozens of
501 c 3's across the state who are
administering
other programs right so this bill
impacts all non-profits too i just want
to point that out and not just
charitable nonprofits 501c3s
unfortunately i can't answer that
particular question because i'm not um
involved from from our perspective it's
more difficult for us to
monitor the um if we don't have the
information about board members and that
sort of thing to um address the um
our oversight responsibilities
other questions
seeing none you're off easy thank you
thanks
oh
um elizabeth
mcguigan
did i get it pronounced right that time
you did thank you chairman
thank you for the opportunity to speak
today regarding sb 302 i just want to
point out i did pass out a copy of my
testimony as well as a statement from
the organization people united for
privacy who was not able to be here
today
so i'm my name is elizabeth mcguigan i'm
director of policy for the philanthropy
roundtable the round table is a network
of charitable donors working to foster
excellence in philanthropy and to
protect philanthropic freedom
senate bill 302 would help strengthen
the vitality and the breadth of civil
society in new hampshire it would uphold
a key pillar of
philanthropic giving the right of
charitable donors to keep their giving
private if they wish
throughout our nation's history the norm
has always been that people are allowed
to choose for themselves whether to be
public or private in their giving and
only in a very narrow set of
circumstances
and such as direct contributions to
political parties and candidates may
this long-standing norm be set aside
now in a time of deep division and with
the rise of so-called cancel culture the
choice to remain anonymous in charitable
giving is crucial
donors to charitable organizations may
have concerns that they're giving to
causes uh that are controversial now or
may become controversial in the future
might trigger retaliation
it's because of this concern that in
1958 the u.s supreme court ruled that
the state of alabama could not force the
naacp to reveal its members and donors
because doing so would infringe on core
first amendment rights by exposing them
to quote
economic reprisal loss of employment
threat of physical coercion and other
manifestations of public hostility
the right to give and associate
privately has been upheld over and over
by the supreme court including in last
summer's americans for prosperity
foundation case
however it's not just the fear of
harassment or retaliation that leads
some donors to wish to remain private
no anonymous giving to charity has
important religious cultural and
practical routes that extend back at
least two millennia
nearly two thousand years ago the roman
senator and philosopher seneca the
younger wrote
quote how sweet how precious is a gift
when he who gives does not permit
himself to be thanked
faith traditions including christianity
judaism islam and hinduism throughout
history have also strongly encouraged
anonymous giving
many philanthropists prefer to give
anonymously in order to be in order to
avoid being inundated with unwanted
solicitations
others prefer for the attention to be
focused on the good work of the
charities that they support rather than
on themselves such as the late pop
singer george michael his generous
support for causes including aid to
cancer patients and helping abused
children was kept anonymous in large
part for this reason
and new hampshire's citizens and
residents are no strangers to anonymous
giving
for example in december an anonymous
private foundation matched donations up
to a hundred thousand dollars for the
new hampshire food bank in what's become
now an annual gift for the organization
in 2017 the food bank also received an
anonymous 1 million donation which
included funds for the organization's
culinary job training program
mobile food pantries and to reduce costs
for the group's 430 partner agencies
we don't know why these givers chose to
remain anonymous but what we do know is
that communities throughout the state
benefited from their unheralded
generosity
now most if not all charitable
organizations in the state also pledge
to honor donor privacy
knowing that the valuable value of
charitable giving is important for the
communities that they serve
senate bill 302 would protect the
long-standing and vital norm of allowing
donors to charitable organizations to
remain private if they wish without the
protections of this measure charitable
organizations would be at risk in the
future of having to violate the privacy
of their donors
in the event of forced disclosure for
even one organization many who prefer to
remain
out of the public eye for a wide variety
of reasons would simply stop giving to a
wide range of groups
limiting the important work that new
hampshire's charities do
so in short new hampshire must
proactively protect those that wish to
give to charitable organizations must
not allow forced disclosures to chill
giving in the state
sb 302 would protect this norm and i
encourage you to consider it
thank you
other questions representative chase
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question i'm just curious
because you're really focusing on the
donors and not all of the other things
that are in this bill if donor was
removed and people could stay anonymous
would that
satisfy
you guys
well you know what i mean thank you for
your question i think that we do focus a
lot on charitable givers but i think
there are a lot of ways that you can be
a donor besides financial gifts if you
are a volunteer board member for example
you may not wish to have a public
association but
as the supreme court ruled in the
americans for prosperity foundation case
the right to associate privately is an
important corollary to freedom of speech
other questions
sigmund thank you for your testimony
today
olivia zink
good afternoon members of the committee
um for the record my name is olivia zink
the executive director for open
democracy
action which is a nonpartisan nonprofit
organization based here in concord with
over 35 000 members and our mission is
really around to protect our democracy
and i live in franklin new hampshire
and i want to thank you for the
opportunity to testify in opposition to
this unnecessary legislation
granite staters across the partisan
perspective
and demographic lines
consistently support transparency in the
democratic process
in recognition of the critical role that
disclosure plays on shining
a light
on the political influence of wealthy
special interests
and to hold
elected officials accountable for and
the public at large
this legislation would reduce the
accountability in our political system
making it easier for wealthy special
interests to make
funding in our elections and making dark
money in new hampshire politics a little
bit darker
this moves transparency in the wrong
direction real transparency is about
knowing who's spending big money in our
elections and holding our government
accountable
on page line one page one line thirty
one it talks about exemptions and i
wanna specifically talk about um on page
two line five
the exemption for campaign finance it is
narrowly defined as 664 for
but the ag's responsibility to enforce
campaign finance is in 666
um also
i just got a new book
of the election laws it's
419 pages and this
is only exempting the 26 pages
around campaign around 664 of this bill
not all of
the important disclosures that are
important in election law
i also wanted to speak about the
exemption for lobbyists which is line
three on page two
new hampshire lobbying laws
really are behind many other states in
public disclosure and i think it's
important for
the public at large to know who's
spending money to influence
and i did post um a nhpr story that
lobbying is nearly impossible to follow
the money in new hampshire and also
quoted former um
attorney general gordon mcdonald
that we need to do better with respects
to lobbying disclosures and we need a
standard of re review for for those
disclosures so i think it's really
important when you look at campaign
finance and lobbying how narrowly this
is scoped those exemptions are not broad
exemptions it also does not exempt
municipal campaign finance so if a
community wants to have those donors
disclosed on who's spending money in
local elections those would also not be
under this exemption
therefore i think it's really important
that voters need to know who's
influencing and spending money to
influence our government so please
either vote interim study or itl on this
bill so that we can protect new
hampshire and our important granite
state from outside influence happy to
take any questions
questions representative smith
thank you mr chair
thank you ms zinke it's always a
pleasure to see you
um when the prime sponsor spoke a little
earlier i might have misheard her but i
thought she said that this does not
apply to electoral
politics and yet
you
are saying that it does can you help me
understand the difference of opinion
yeah so page five um i mean page two
line five
where it talks about campaign finance it
only um
it only exempts rsa 664
which is only 26 pages of the whole book
of campaign of of election loss
so the piece around the ag's enforcement
is in a different statue for campaign
finance laws i think you want to at
least allow the attorney general if
they're investigating donors to to be
you know able to do that work of
investigating donors but they're not
under this exemption this exemption is
only this
sort of small part of the total loss
thank you
other questions
tim
excuse me representative horrigan
well thank you mr sheriff um
so i've
um
something
something that goes on a lot even
something goes on a lot even the
existing law and this doesn't apply to
you specifically you're wearing an
orange badge you
file all the
you file complete disclosures for the
secretary of state's office we have a
large number of individuals who come
here to the state house over and over
again who don't have the orange badges
aren't filing the um
aren't filing the disclosures because
they claim to just have advocates and
not lobbyists so
um would this bill
do anything to solve that problem or
would it make it even worse
i i know that there was one institute
that rated new hampshire a d in um
lobbying disclosures i think we rank
pretty low uh in the threshold that's
needed for lobbying disclosure and also
if if we do fix rsa 15 which is the
lobbying law to make more broad
disclosures for lobbyists would this
just apply to the statute as written
currently or or would it apply more
broadly if uh additional lobbying
disclosure is ever passed and i will say
that i have worked to try to increase
lobbying disclosure and failed pretty
miserably um so it's not a popular topic
any other questions
yeah representative wolper
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question i am confused
so rsa 664 as far as i understand it
which i don't have the laws in front of
me so but as far as i understand rss
a664 deals with the political donations
to political committees
if logan and this bill talks to donors
so isn't that the appropriate part of
the law for it to address
i i think you're yes 66 it should
appropriate 666 664 but should it also
appropriate 666 which allows the
attorney general to investigate
the law under 664.
are you all set
uh mm-hmm there other other questions
sing then thank you for your testimony
today
nathan white
good afternoon mr chair members of
committee my name is nathan white i'm
from the department of health and human
services i'm the director of contracts
and procurement
at health and human services and i'm
here just to speak on one technical
issue
on page one of the bill um line 23
there's a provision that would prohibit
public agencies or public bodies
from requesting or requiring a current
or perspective contractor or grantee to
provide a public agency or public body
with a list of entities exempt from the
federal income tax under section 501 c
the internal revenue code to which it
has provided financial or non-financial
support
so our department on any given day has
between 800 and 1000 active contracts
roughly 60 to 70 percent of those
contracts uh include
federal dollars every federal dollar
that we receive that we provide in a sub
award or we provide in a grant agreement
or whatever it might be
those are subject to two cfr part 200
commonly known as federal uniform
guidance federal uniform guidance
requires that we protect those funds we
have to follow certain procedures we
have to conduct risk
assessments we have to conduct
monitoring once those dollars go out the
door
and as part of that
we we do sometimes we act as a
pass-through entity or we provide funds
to a contractor and then that contractor
or sub-recipient
they then provide a sub-award
it it would be challenging for us to
to oversee and monitor
those funds if we were unable to ask our
immediate contractor who did they
provide several words to so the domestic
coalition for domestic and sexual
violence we commonly you know we will
give them
x amount of dollars for x purpose and
then they will provide those to 12
member organizations or crisis centers
um that that's just an example so this
particular provision um would be
challenging for us to still comply with
the federal requirements that we're
subject to
another more technical aspect and i
apologize for being the one here
bringing the the technical nuance
aspects that are relatively boring
honestly
but another key provision here though is
uh our standard uh state terms and
conditions um p37 that requires every
state agency this isn't just dhhs this
is any agency whether it's general funds
federal funds or other funds
to
review and approve
any subcontracts that a contractor that
we provide funding to may have so that's
just another potential issue that i just
wanted to elevate to the committee
are there questions
sing them thank you for your testimony
today thank you
greg moore
good morning mr chairman members of the
committee thanks for the opportunity to
speak here today for the record my name
is greg moore i am the state director
with americans for prosperity here in
new hampshire
and i'm here today to speak in support
of senate bill 302
i actually come here wearing several
hats i am the state director for
americans for prosperity the state
director for americans for prosperity
foundation and someone who sits and has
sat on several
non-profit boards as i'm sure a lot of
the other members of the committee have
of local new hampshire non-profits so i
come at it from a number of different
perspectives
uh
i think talking a little bit
about the history
of this issue is important to understand
sort of the rationale for the
legislation
uh and i'll just want to i'll just say
that that we were not involved in the
development or construction of this law
but when you're the name plaintiff in
the most recent supreme court case it
kind of pulls you into an issue like
this
so
the
donor protections exist from the mid 50s
this was in the beginnings of the civil
rights movement the
attorney general of of alabama
requested
the
donor records from the naacp
now i'm sure you can imagine why the
naacp would be fairly hesitant to hand
those overs and the chilling effect it
would have on future
future uh contributions importantly for
them but also for the for their donors
the impact that that would have on them
and of course the supreme court ruled
that this is protected under the first
amendment under the free association
clause
uh so
americans for prosperity foundation was
surprised in 2015
when the california department of
justice
demanded our donor records
we obviously brought litigation and and
what went on for
six years before there was an ultimate
resolution last year in the us supreme
court which again reaffirmed the right
to to the privacy of donors and i
actually have a list of there were 300
different groups that uh joined in uh
miki briefs
on that particular legislation and it's
as diverse as from the aclu to the human
rights campaign to the gun owners of
america to the reason foundation so it's
literally all over the map including
humane societies uh private universities
etc i'm happy to to give that out to the
committee
now now i want to point out this is not
about us um
i can't imagine any attorney general or
any department of justice in new
hampshire in the right mind would
go after us away california did
considering we had the resources and
gumption to take them all the way to the
us supreme court
of course
if you were a smaller non-profit and the
idea of a twenty thousand dollar or
fifty thousand dollar legal bill came up
that that could have devastating impacts
to your small non-profit so
this this uh
this legislation would simply make sure
that that that would never happen and no
new hampshire
charity would would end up going through
what we go through or what we went
through for six years so that's what we
want to forestall here and i know that i
know the philanthropy roundtable is
doing these efforts uh nationally
and i think it's important work
i think a few things to keep in mind
we mentioned rsa664 i will say i will
say that in new hampshire under 664
if you are engaged in any election
hearing you have to file a political
committee whether you're a non-profit or
any other entity
we americans for prosperity files as a
political committee
and any other any other nonprofit has to
that would not change
at all under this under this legislation
they would still have to file file with
with the secretary of state's office
one last one last point i'd like to make
to the committee is is just as i said
the impact that this this would have on
think about the local smaller
non-profits they don't have the
resources to go and and
go to court and protect their
constitutional rights so i think it's
it's important to understand
putting that hat on from my perspective
of how if we had got a demand letter
from the department of justice
how we would handle that obviously we'd
have to go find legal counsel and pay
them and and
again the idea of a substantial legal
bill could have a major impact on on a
small non-profit here in new hampshire
ultimately they probably would just
comply in other words just give away
their constitutional rights because they
don't have the the resources to defend
themselves and that to me is
particularly concerning so with that uh
i'll in my testimony be happy to take
any questions from the committee
questions for mr moore
uh
representative you mr chair and thank
you for taking my question i'm i'm not
familiar with the case uh now the naacp
the 1958 case that we've heard
referenced or actually with the case in
california but
in 1958 in the w
um
cp i i mean my gut
response i mean thought you said is that
they didn't want to reveal their donors
because they probably thought they would
be killed they weren't chilling effect
on donors so
you had said that they didn't want to
give it out for the chili effect on
donors i'm just wondering with your
familiarity is that the reason
i well i i i'm 100 convinced that that's
true that you're right that that the the
health and safety of their donors would
be a top priority as well but beyond
that there would be a chilling effect
for future donors uh i i'll tell you i
in the process of doing fundraising
um have to admit when you work for a
politically active nonprofit
a lot of your donors ask if their
contribution will be kept private it's
because
while they might believe in that they
don't want their name associated because
they might be in business doing
something else that would have a
negative impact and frankly the top
reason i think is that they're afraid of
further unwanted contributions in other
words if you show up on a list as a
donor to one organization there'll be a
conga line of fundraisers from every
other organization that will line right
up and and uh
starts listing you as well and and uh if
you've ever hung out with some larger
donors who are known to give
contributions uh
donor fatigue isn't just isn't just
being tired of giving money sometimes
it's just tired of being asked for money
i hope that's helpful
representative lorenzo
thank you mr kieran thank you mr moore
for taking my questions i noticed that
you um sent around a handout but there
are no citations no references i mean
what is this
so
uh that is a list of the organizations
that filed the miki briefs before the
supreme court uh the decision uh the
case was uh americans for prosperity
foundation versus bonta
and bonta is the attorney general for
the state of california
a follow-up place and what was the date
on that
so the the case itself was argued uh
early in the 21 uh
uh states uh use sorry
supreme court season and it came out in
june of 2021.
thank you thank you
other questions
representative simpson
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question mr moore
um
this that you just handed to us so i'm i
guess i'm thinking through
the difference between keeping board
members names private and keeping donors
names private
and i'm wondering um this list
about
your case in california was that
specifically about donors or was that
also about
board members so that so the initial
demand on the part of the california
department of justice was for donors it
did not involved
as
um
so the
americans prosperity foundation is a
corporation that's uh based in in
delaware so it's a delaware-based
corporation so it would follow delaware
law as far as reporting and then
obviously it would be considered a
foreign corporation in the other states
in which it it operates but to your to
your question it was just the demand was
just for donors okay great thank you
and then um oh sorry can i follow up
thank you
i'm thinking about donors to nonprofits
and how
like the ag's responsibility to protect
the public and my
my thinking is that a lot of donors want
transparency about who's making
decisions about the budget and about
where the money that they're giving is
going
so i'm wondering in the course of this
like how you how you would talk about
balancing those those interests
again that's a great question because i
come at it from a number of different
angles um i will say i will say that
that in in my donor meetings for raising
money for americans for prosperity
america's prosperity foundation i get
asked a lot of questions and we go
through the entire process with our
prospective donors
that's obviously for for larger donors
and not so much for the person you're
doing a male solicitation for 25 is
obviously a little bit different
standard but if you're asking someone
for a six-figure gift you're going to
get asked a lot of questions um some of
those presentations literally will be
like four or five hours
and and i will say i will say that that
um
donors ask those questions and and
at the first instance
i think it's might be something that the
donor's a little short
as far as asking those questions saying
that saying that you need to have the
department of justice
oversee that i understand the department
of justice
perception i've certainly
i've
i certainly get the fact why they would
like to have access to more information
but again having that access to
information how that information can be
used
it could potentially show up somewhere
else if it were if that information came
to the department of justice it could be
subject perhaps to a 91 a request
and then suddenly all that becomes
public via that that route so i mean
there are ways of once that information
is transferred
for it to become public in a way that
could be damaging to the individuals
involved
can i thank you
i'm trying to
think through now like one more step
which is like
so all the 501cs
are
exempt from taxation
on this money
so it seems to me that the 501cs then
have a responsibility
like a greater responsibility to the
public
to show what public good they're doing
and how
then
i don't know i'm just
you know what i'm trying to say is like
what is what's again like what's the
balance
i do and and of course there are a ton
of
non-charitable non-profits that do
incredible work uh
and
it's also important to understand it and
i understand this from department of
justice standpoint
of there are scam non-profits right
there are groups out there that just
basically set up a shell and put
together a couple nice glossies flyers
and maybe they have a really charismatic
person
and
uh at the at the first instance uh at
the first instance though i would say
that that it's
the responsibility
of the donor to be able to to work
through that i mean i i i
large donors ask so many questions they
do and um i think it's probably because
they have been solicited by some of
these potential scam non-profits
uh but
the risk of subjecting all the good
non-profits
uh
to
potential potential harm
you know that obviously you're the
legislature you make that public policy
decision uh but i would say i would say
that the the protection offered to the
non-profits doing great work every day
is is outweighs the harm
representative smith
thank you mr chair good afternoon miss
moore
you just did something that
made my mind take a leap
to frm
in which
ultimately
the state was held
responsible
because it did not catch the fact
that there was some
inappropriate conduct going on
my
mind connected the two because if the
state is responsible for
verifying eligibility
under um
c
for
getting reports
etc etc
if in fact there is an organization that
is not using
donated money in a way that is
appropriate
and if the state has no way of
knowing that
nonetheless wouldn't the state
be responsible as it was
uh determined in the frm case
you raise a great great point
representative i think i think that
potentially by injecting the state into
this
you're there is a liability risk for the
state that they that they're taking on
as we now see as the
past budget showed
um where
the the settlement funds are right there
some settlement funds are in the budget
i i would also say this uh it's
important to understand that the
nonprofit world
doesn't operate in a vacuum
there are a number of organizations
that review non-profits
uh
guidestar and
other organizations that actually go and
they review it
and
if they find for example that that a uh
that a non-profit is giving away a
relatively small amount of the other
funds that they raise and i've seen
non-profits that
they give away like 10 or 15 percent of
the funds that they raise and the rest
all goes to overhead and organization
they get downgraded and when those
organizations like guidestar downgrade
a non-profit it becomes a lot harder for
them to raise money inappropriately so i
know that's not quite appropriate it
just came to my head
so i thought but i wanted to add that
but i think you you raise a great point
representative
other questions
sing none thank you for your testimony
thank you
melissa margolin
mr chairman members of the committee
good afternoon my name is alyssa
margalin i know i've addressed this
committee several times about housing
issues i'm here today with a different
hat on i'm here as a public policy
consultant with the new hampshire center
for non-profits our ceo kathleen verdin
couldn't be here today so i'll be
providing her testimony
the new hampshire center for nonprofits
is opposed to senate bill 302
um the center is our umbrella
organization in the state we have 700
members
the entity is dedicated to strengthening
and giving voice to the nonprofit sector
through leadership collaboration and
learning opportunities
overall we oppose this legislation
because we believe there are a number of
unintended consequences to these
proposals as has been mentioned this is
um
the the source of this proposal is
really a national effort around donor
privacy we really think that this
proposal is in search of a problem that
does not exist in the granite state so
i'm going to talk a little bit about
that first i want to raise an issue
around the role that was mentioned
earlier about preserving the public
trust
over the last couple years of pandemic
related challenges i think it's clear to
all of us about the important role that
nonprofits play in your community
our sector in the state often plays the
role that government would play in
another state
it is really important that our
nonprofit sector in new hampshire know
how to effectively manage finances
engage in transparency around governance
avoid self-dealing and remain
politically
nonpartisan the new layer of proposed
restraints on public agencies and right
to know public bodies regarding
regarding the records of non-profits
could erode our public trust here in the
granite state of course we do value our
rights
of privacy and we talk a lot about
privacy in the boardroom
but we think here we have appropriate
transparency
that ultimately make
create a a
an agreement between our donors our
volunteers and our leaders uh and uh and
the nonprofit sector and help us being
more successful at executing on our
missions
another
likely adverse consequence to additional
confidentiality
is what anything would happen when you
have like just a lack of transparency a
lack of sunshine in these highly
divisive times there are few societal
spaces now that are nonpartisan
we at the center encourage advocacy um
and we honor
but we do think it's important that c3s
remember that they can't endorse
candidates nor give money for public
office but there is a growing amount of
pressure to move money through the c3
sector and something that we're we're
watching and concerned with um and in
the last um administration there was an
effort to repeal the johnson amendment
that would have allowed more political
money to move through the doc the the
non-profit sector
that we
we work to oppose
um
we also as as noted earlier by the
charitable trust unit our trust our
doj here in the state does not ask for a
donor list they never have
and this is already settled law in the
um in the banta decision that's been
mentioned overall we do find this
unnecessary and potentially harmful we
do appreciate there was some efforts to
amend the legislation in the senate but
we don't think it went far enough it's
still a head scratcher for many of our
members things that have come up can we
publicly thank volunteers
can we publicly thank donors i mean we
know that that's kind of the bread and
butter of a lot of nonprofits right is
that is the list and that you're in this
club and that club and we also know that
so many of our nonprofits honor
anonymity regularly for donors who who
request it um
what about the administrative burdens of
compulsory confidentiality what does
that look like and what happens if they
make an error um and uh and and uh have
inadvertent disclosures um this was not
a concern raised
inside the state by the nonprofit sector
and seems to go further than needed
um this is new hampshire we need to be
accountable to one another and so we
urge your committee to find uh the the
proposal and expedient to legislate
representative simpsons
thank you
thank you for this and thank you for
taking my question um
i actually had a question about the
penalties section and so i'm glad that
you raised it um
we haven't talked really about it yet
but i wonder if your
organization had a response specifically
to the
like the dollar amounts and the
penalties or how that would work or did
you talk about that yeah i don't think
i'm prepared to talk specifically about
the the penalties in the in the proposal
but just to say it it's as we talked
about the
this kind of
scrappy nature of a lot of our community
organizations that they're so impactful
you know any kind of additional
administrative burdens um you know could
be a concern and obviously if there are
penalties associated with that that
could have a real adverse consequence on
a smaller nonprofit there are also
issues around like there's some safety
issues that have come up like what if
there's a question about a coach and
some background that a coach and what if
a parent makes an inquiry
like and and just we we would be putting
we'd be tying the hands
of a system that seems to be working for
us right now
represent macbeth
thank you chair gordon and thank you for
taking my question
so out of your 700 members or whatever
have you and i know times are different
but have you noticed any of this donor
fatigue or is there
a drop-off in um you know
donor participation or contribution
um well as so new hampshire gives is
right around the corner and last year
was the the most successful new
hampshire gives we've ever had
um
uh granite staters have been
very generous in response to the
pandemic
and i think our government leaders as
well in terms of making sure resources
could uh get to the nonprofits the
non-profit emergency relief program that
came out of the karzak money we were the
first state in the country to make sure
that we were bolstering non-profits and
philanthropy i think generally is has
increased in the state on a national
basis our numbers look lower than other
states but that could be because of the
way it's counted um
and connected to religious organizations
because we have fewer of them in this
state
thank you thank you
representative horgan
so i've noticed these philanthropic
organizations um
they often advertise you know you look
at their
their websites they frequently talk
about all the other philanthropic
organizations that they're associated
with so they're not necessarily
i mean some people do make anonymous
donations but they're not necessarily
secretive about who they're working with
when it comes to talking to potential
donors but it seems like uh
this would shut
um government agencies including law
enforcement and also uh
you know government agencies that are
sub contracting with these organizations
so it seems like this
would uh shut off a lot of oversight
well without restricting their ability
to
um
use their affiliations to promote
themselves to
the
potential donors or other groups they
want to partner with thank you for the
question representative and as the
charitable trust unit
noted earlier
identifying scamming you know is really
important in uh in the nonprofit sector
so if you are
a veritable non-profit doing good say
around breast cancer i know in my
community we have a great organization
called breast cancer stories
and uh and another entity that you know
comes in and is fraudulently um securing
funds from your community that's less
for you um so we it's a partnership that
we have with government to make sure and
and the public interest to make sure
that um we're holding up the
organizations that that are doing things
the right way okay thanks
other questions
seeing none thank you
so much
and
is there anyone else who hasn't
testified who wishes to testify
yes sir
good afternoon mr chairman members of
the committee i apologize for not
putting in a testimony request my name
is john conforti i represent the new
hampshire lottery um and i will be brief
uh the new hampshire lottery commission
oversees charitable gaming in the state
um games of chance bingo lucky seven um
and we're not taking a position on this
bill but we did want to um
identify that there are elements of
senate bill 302 which are in conflict
with um some of the current uh statutes
relating to
bingo lucky seven
and games of chance i doubt that bingo
was top of mind when this uh
legislation was drafted um so we wanted
to just make a note of the fact that
as regulators of that entity we do
request
during the application process and
during our financial reviews
who is involved in the charity with
these games
in the case of bingo and lucky seven the
charities themselves actually operate
the games
and therefore we do require oversight to
know who those members are that are
participating um and so there are a
number of statutes to a7d6
287 d22
287 e5 e7 e9 e21 and e24 all of which
would be impacted by senate bill 302 um
would restrict our ability to identify
and be able to license uh charities for
that gaming activity um this is
obviously all voluntary activity on
behalf of the charity um that they come
to us seeking a license we do not go out
to them
but we do would would encourage you to
consider if this legislation is moving
forward
consider an exemption
for those statutes that are currently in
place which allow us
to license those charities for
charitable gaming be happy to take any
questions
representative wolper
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question can you give us that
list i mean
i can and i can also submit it
afterwards if that would be easier
whichever way it works okay i just want
to get it
i think just to to to be on the safe
side i i can submit that to to you and
the chair um after this hearing
that'd be super if you send it to us in
an email we'll distribute it to the
committee excellent thank you
representative smith
thank you mr chair thank you very much
um can you tell me why given the
strength of your testimony which seems
to me to be rather important
nonetheless you're not taking a position
on the bill uh it's our position as an
agency uh not to take a position on the
overall bill and again
with we just wanted to
let make note that there's a technical
issue between
uh
standing law right now and and the bill
um as an agency we we try not to um to
take positions on bills we just try to
educate um to to
tell you what the impact would be for
our agency
um
thank you
representative oregon
yes when i heard the words trust in
lottery in the same paragraph i
immediately thought of uh
immediately thought of device to set up
a
trust to receive the winnings of your
lottery ticket but i guess that would
normally not be a charitable trust
although i suppose it could be if that's
what the winner wanted to do so is
anything in that bill which would
interfere with uh
that practice which many jackpot winners
uh choose to take advantage of
it it should not because as as you're as
you identify that is those are not 501c
um trusts or or charitable organizations
that um
that claim those tickets we have had
charities where we've had people who've
donated the tickets to charities and
they come forward but they're also more
than happy to um
publicize that they've uh they've won
powerball or mega millions and we're
very happy to provide them with that
check
all right thanks
representative chase did you have a
question thank you thanks for taking my
question i'm just looking at the report
from the senate did you bring these up
in front of the senate and um
what what did they say we did not
represent chase we were not advised of
the bill and and we were not aware of
the bill as it went through the senate
um the department of justice made us
aware uh of the bill's presence um
during the at the end of the senate
process after it had already uh passed
through so we did not have an
opportunity or we missed on the
opportunity to identify these issues for
the senate so that is ultimately our
responsibility we just we were not aware
of it
other questions
would you fill out a pink card and
submit it to us i will thank you i want
to make sure we spell your name right
yes
thank you thank you
anybody else who wishes to testify
there was a request to have
representative macbeth you asked if you
could ask another question of ms quinlan
is that correct i did
i i wanted to know um
could the historic nature of this it was
brought up before
the tax relief that donors get
historically was that kind of why they
got the tax release i mean could you
tell us a little bit about that sure and
how much is it i don't know is it dollar
per dollar
well one of the reasons um that
the public
uh
first of all charities serve public
purposes
and that's why they're provided with a
tax exemption inc federal income tax and
oftentimes property taxes
so it's because they serve that public
purpose that they get those exemptions
and so as a result there has to be some
oversight and some transparency
okay
so
okay i'll thank you i'll i'll follow up
thanks thank you
any other question any other people
wishing to testify
seeing none we will close the hearing on
senate bill 302.
and our committee will be in recess
until next wednesday
the 13th
at nine o'clock
not a problem
and i actually spelled it right before
huh
oh
okay
all right
um
oh
what
i'm doing
okay